foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well hey everybody look Tom's in this
video instead of the video next one
that's actually yeah I just guessed it
though it's not that good
that's a little bit better just a little
piece of you within the one next door I
got a message from uh from Trey and he
said that he's like you may not think
much about it but he's like that little
joke about Tom big in the next video
over is one of those little quirky
things that I love about you guys that
we always like make the joke about you
being well like I said it's always
because I'm usually already running the
stream by the time he gets in there so
he can't see like where he's sitting you
know what I mean oh my computer's doing
all kind of crazy [__] over there I
don't know what it's doing so uh yeah
hey everybody what's going on uh tonight
we're gonna be talking about uh this
scumbag here Mr Jared Fogle which
um I guess he was pretty well known
around the world I feel like but I feel
like it was mostly kind of mostly an
American thing I just remember from
commercials and he really didn't make a
big impression well yeah yeah was just
some guy that claimed to have lost a lot
of weight on sub well he did I mean did
he own the company or something he's
just a spokesman no no he just we'll get
into that we'll get into that he was
just like a random [__] he's a random
dude I just remember seeing him on there
and
I didn't really care about him just you
know what I mean
it was just more media of the time there
was a [__] ton of this kind of stuff
going on and it was 90s I think it was
it was no it was 2000s was it 2000s it
was 90s the first commercial was in 2000
and actually they aired like a bunch of
commercials over the two they pretty
much until 2015 when I remember I
remember him I just thought I first saw
him in the 90s no okay I got the times
wrong then yep it was two thousand and
then he was talking about how much
weight he lost yeah it was a lot I
remember that uh kanak said didn't this
guy just get released um no he's
actually not eligible for parole until
um and there's no guarantee he'll be let
out then however uh just about a month
ago there was a documentary about him
called I think it's called catching a
monster so maybe that's what it was but
yeah he's not um eligible for parole for
several more years I actually they gave
him well you know he got a plea deal I
guess so that's why he got like a
slightly lesser sentence but
he got uh I think he ended up getting 15
years 15 and a half years something like
that but he has to serve as it's federal
prison so he has to serve like 80 of it
or 85 I don't remember what the law is
but um so he's not eligible for parole
until like he served 13 years so now
he's still in there but he's in federal
prison and from what I hear uh he's
having like a fairly cushy time of it
which
is kind of a shame because he's a
dirtbag so you know yeah there's that
he did get his ass kicked once but not
since then
so you know okay
but uh yeah Danny Rowling was in here
telling some uh telling some jokes about
it's funny because the the uh was it the
mild cholesterol problem the child
molesterol problem yeah I had heard that
joke before
um I don't remember where I heard it
though there was a lot of jokes going
around about what after that came out
like in 2015 yes and I've also heard the
one about spending his life trying to
get into smaller pants I've heard that
one as well
um so yeah I've heard all the Jared
jokes well just because I've been like
researching this [__] for like
three or four days at this point and
I've you know watched a whole bunch of
different documentaries about him and
like write a whole bunch of stuff about
him and [__] like that so
so I've heard all the sandwich jokes and
it's funny because
just now before the show started
um Tom was telling me he was out on his
motorcycle and he got caught in the rain
it was a big like uh rainstorm this
afternoon and he had to like pull into
the Circle K to get out of the rain and
he went in and he said he got like a six
six inch sub or something like or a foot
long sub and I was like oh so it kind of
ties in with the thing yeah it wasn't uh
it was a Subway
no it was one of their pre-wrapped ones
although there is a Subway in that
Circle K uh no not that Circle okay oh
not that oh you're not talking about the
one right by the house no no the one by
the one by our house has the subway in
it yeah I've never eaten at it though
the one by Lowe's the one that has the
uh oh okay I gotcha I gotcha yeah and it
didn't it didn't have a Subway I would
have eaten it
but um they had the the pre-wrapped ones
they also had like the sandwiches that
you like the little half sandwich the
little sandwiches little triangles yeah
they have those they had a whole they
had even a wider selection really yeah
they had about seven or eight different
now yeah
and uh the the um
the footlong was a different brand but
it was good bread was good everything
yeah
like the Circle K sandwiches I've never
got a bad one from there and we've
gotten a lot of sandwiches from Circle K
like from their ready to eat section
because you know we always kind of want
it's like oh I just kind of want to say
much like when we're coming home from
the club it was good I didn't have any
lettuce on it yeah see and that's what
stopped me before
because lettuce doesn't package it'll
just be [__] soppy yeah it'll get all
wilty uh and um so they wisely left the
lettuce off of it
a lot of mayo a lot of cheese
but I'm obviously gonna make it good
yeah I mean the best one I think kind of
pickles the best one I think that from
um Circle K that I always get is
um it's chicken salad but it also has
cranberries in it yeah
and that's also very good but yeah I get
that almost every time and it's always
good yeah so I was headed back home and
the [__] weather was good and I look
up look up the street there's just like
a black wall it kind of came out of
nowhere because I was at work in Daytona
and uh the accounting lady Barbara she
said to me she's like she's like oh my
God like it's [__] pitch black
outside all of a sudden and then my
little thing on the bottom said heavy
rain soon and I was like me right when I
have to drive home it was clearly
delineated there was just like a black
wall coming at me and I was like oh [__]
there was cars in traffic in front of me
and it hit boom and it was all the wind
too and it just immediately I saw all
these brake lights everybody slamming
their brakes so I slammed mine on and I
was just on that little Buell man
[__] that little screamer see I
didn't know that you were out and about
on that like that's yeah I'm glad I
didn't know I felt like it was on the
Millennium Falcon I had entered the
[__] asteroid field man hell yeah the
[__] it was blowing me all over the
[__] place wasn't so much to raid I
was immediately stopped to the [__]
bone yeah just immediately wet to the
Bone but but strangely enough you know
on your helmet your head stays dry so
you have an illusion of comfort yeah
like well at least my head's dry
yeah at least you're not like water
dripping in your eyes yeah the rest of
your body is just [__] ice cold
though you know and it goes from Florida
heat to ice cold [__] quickly
wind was buffered to me all around and
[__] the cars were all slowing down
even they couldn't drive
they're on four wheels I was gonna say
I'm going [__] this I'm getting off
despite Florida which you know it's I I
feel like the rest of the country has a
perception of it it's like this sunny
Paradise which like some of it is but it
also uh we also have torrential rains
pretty much every day like at least in
the summer time yeah and you would think
that people that live here would be used
to that they absolutely are not
um people in Florida drive like idiots
anyway just as a Baseline and the second
it starts where now I'm not even talking
about rain rain I'm just talking about
like sprinkling and stuff like that
people just immediately lose their minds
and forget how to drive completely yeah
you cannot reason with floating
extraordinary you can't reason with
Floridian it's extraordinary I mean and
and I'm a proud Florida man and Florida
man [__] those [__] are dumb
I just say something and it happens hit
it it was doing that before you were in
here to be fair something wrong yeah I
think it's kind of like
you know prices went up on those lights
gonna light you know what I mean it's
just gonna do whatever but yeah that's I
mean on my on my hour drive home today I
so many times was like what what that
what what are you doing like I could
have I was like they're baffling this is
people are just baffling they will fight
through [__] traffic and Bob and
weave 90 miles an hour through traffic
and run right into his traffic jam yeah
like they tried to get around I had a
guy do that it doesn't make any [__]
sense like there was there was a car
going in for him and like everybody had
slowed down some I was on 92 which
you're technically only supposed to go
55 but everybody goes about 75
um or 80 including me but um you know
what I mean miles per hour for you
Europeans yeah yeah that's fast but um
yeah so but everybody had slowed down
because it was raining so it's like I
was going probably about 70. the person
next to me like in this Lane was also
going about 70. we were kind of like
they were a little bit in front of me
like that and this [__] douchebag
like comes like roaring up behind me and
like gets into this tiny Gap like in
front of me in the car in front of me
and he couldn't go any place yeah
because it was another car like I'm like
what the [__] was that all and I even
like went in the mirror I'm like
hell of a drug just crack is a hell of a
dream like what did that accomplish yeah
nothing now you're stuck there yeah and
I'm stuck behind your stupid ass yeah
they'll fight through [__] a quarter
mile of traffic to obviously [__] run
into a traffic jam I mean you can see it
you can see that this gridlock up there
and they're fighting to get in it
they're just stupid yes dude I don't get
it I see it every day but I don't get it
Anthony says are his big britches
available on eBay I thought they said
that after they retired the um the
campaign that he was said that he was
going to donate them to a museum but I
don't know if that ever happened so I
don't know where the big pants ever
ended up because the very big pants were
like very very famous
um granther says Jared's big claim is he
lost 100 pounds eating only Subways what
was on those subs cucumber slices and
some lettuce I can answer that question
it was not a hundred pounds he lost
245 pounds is how much he lost
and what he ate every single day
was he ate half a turkey sub with
vegetables on it no mayo no cheese no no
dressing no nothing like that it
wouldn't have made a difference um and a
bit and a little bag of baked potato
chips and a diet soda and then for
dinner he had a footlong veggie sub also
with no dressing no one about diet
metabolism
um there's a lot of misconceptions about
it it wouldn't have mattered if he had
all those extras on there
if you're once you're [__] fat all
right it's hard to maintain that fat
unless there's
something medically wrong with you and
that your metabolism is just [__] up
you have to eat a lot to maintain that
amount of weight well yeah we'll get
into that yeah I mean it's work
that's part of the reason why I'm not
[__] gigantic with all the [__] that
I do I just not I'm just not a big eater
I was when I was talking to Ryan that
Ryan's a bodybuilder over there [__]
goes to Silverbacks that's the name of
that [__] gym he's like 265 pounds
yeah he's [__] the monster all right
we're talking about a guy he's a smaller
version of maybe like Lou Lou Ferrigno
his
biceps are bigger than my [__] thighs
and I got pretty nice thighs I do can
[__]
probably bench 700 pounds he's a power
lifter too not only is a bodybuilder I
asked him he said how much do you eat
and it was when I'm on a cycle eat 4 000
calories a day
and I just couldn't [__] imagine he
goes I gotta weigh all my food out oh
just you wait until we get into this
story
[Laughter]
and I'm like and he's like well how much
you been eating anything I've been
telling my Cycles this and that and I
eat about 1500 to 1200 calories a day
which is low I don't eat much and he's
like well that's why you're so small
I said really he goes he goes yeah you
got to eat a lot
you where do you think the mass is going
to come from
I was just thinking of your gated fat
though I was like why'd you probably
just get fat it just says just eat a lot
of meat a lot of fresh vegetables but
when you look at how low calories meat
is there's not a lot of calories there
you got to eat a lot of it to reach 3
000 calories 4 000 calories
but these eating [__] two dozen eggs
a day and
I mean and on top of all kinds of other
[__] [__] whey protein and steaks and
[__] whole chickens and
that's expensive diet man
you'd eat yourself literally out of the
house at home you'd [__] spend a
[__] thousand dollars a day thousand
dollars a [__] month just on [__]
grocery bills man
and I can't imagine like well [__] man
we go to koiwan yeah and he eats three
four plates worth of stuff and I can eat
maybe a plate and a half before I'm like
yeah but be sick yeah it's just it's too
much yeah so it's like I don't I see
people put away like all this like and
I'm like how do you do that like I would
throw up if I ate that much so this guy
losing weight off the eating subs that's
I'm not even impressed by that well like
I said I'll get into like what how it
happened and all that because to
maintain the amount of weight that he
had before he has to eat all kinds of
[__] so eat eating a sub yeah a day and
some other [__] yeah you're gonna lose a
lot of weight
you're gonna lose a lot of weight if you
weigh 300 something pounds you know it
takes a lot to keep that amount of
weight on
like I said unless there's something
wrong yeah like unless you have some
kind of like
glandular those people that are morbidly
obese that lay up in the bed and they
got a [__] cut the door open and
wider or take the [__] out the
window on a crane to get into the
hospital and [__]
their families feeding those people
they have to eat a lot
you know what I mean yeah I mean once
you get to a certain weight yeah you
have to like maintain the weight yeah
it's got to be maintained so you know
I'm not all that sympathetic I mean it's
a it's a mental problem some they're
just addicted to food or they're trying
to kill themselves
I couldn't eat to eat what they're
eating
and all you got if you were to just take
that away and give them anything if you
could give them two pizzas a day and
he'd lose weight but yeah well if you
give them anything less than what they
were yeah before yeah well and that's
what a lot of people said with the Jared
thing too is that you know
considering how much he was eating
before like any amount then of course
you're gonna lose yeah and usually like
I said if you're real morbidly obese
like that if you start eating
substantially less then the weight will
come off very quickly yeah at first it's
not great for your health
um doing those crash diets like that but
um you know I would argue too that being
425 pounds as he was is also not very
good for your health which we'll get
into in a little bit too because he was
having all kind of problems now you try
that on me
give me a sub and some [__] Diet Coke
and [__] like that am I gonna lose
weight no
no I don't weigh enough
I've had my weight's pretty stable I've
had days where I've eaten substantially
less than what he ate in a day though
but like I said
um I think they calculated like the
sandwiches that he ate because he would
pretty much eat the same thing every day
and um they calculated that that was
like a little less than 2 000 calories
which that's you know considering how
much he was eating before and how much
he weighed that was like essentially a
starvation diet
um for what he was
what he had previously been eating and
hence why he lost so much weight but
um but like I said I've gone days where
I've eaten less than that like yeah a
sandwich and a half
and like I said that's
I don't know I the thing about it too
and I kind of want to get into this a
little bit too is because Subway they
had their um you know in conjunction
with Jared's uh you know him being their
spokesman or whatever they did the whole
uh trying to do the eat fresh thing and
it's like they were trying to like imply
that their food was like healthier than
other fast food places which I guess
some of it is like in the sense that
it's customizable and you don't
necessarily have to put like all the
high fat [__] on there but
you know if you go in there and just say
I'm gonna get a Subway sandwich it's
healthier than a Big Mac I'm like well
that depends on what kind of sandwich
you get and what the [__] you put on it
because if you sit there and slather it
with mayonnaise and dressing and cheese
and everything like that yeah it's gonna
have way more calories than a [__]
Big Mac you might as well just see the
Big Mac you know what I'm saying so
especially if it's like a foot long but
yeah if you go in there and get like a
veggie sub you know with nothing much on
it except vegetables and [__] like that
then yeah that's a lot healthier but you
know yeah
um Ian England said eggs chicken rice
broccoli and cottage cheese are my
go-to's yeah you're a bodybuilder too
yeah yeah yeah I love egg three thousand
four thousand calories he told me I'd
have to eat around 3 000 calories
but he's not talking about civilian
calories where it's got chocolate in it
now ice cream and [__] oh yeah that'd be
easy to hit 3 000 calories of that [__]
yeah just have like a few milkshakes
yeah a couple of Milkshakes that's right
that's not the calories we're talking
about we're talking about that's we're
talking about chicken broccoli you know
[__] greens cottage cheese and you
need to eat a lot of broccoli to get
three thousand yeah yeah you need a lot
of broccoli you need to eat like a
couple three couple two or three chicken
breasts a meal on top all this other
[__] they eat and then like you know
six eggs and then you know some protein
[__] Shake whey protein you're
drinking that with it so and and they
eat all day
you know there's they're eating stuff in
between meals
they're just [__] protein synthesis
machines dudes huge man he's like 260
pounds maybe about five percent body fat
I mean he's dangerously low between five
and ten percent body fat dude looks
[__] great about 35
he could just rip a car door right off
you know motherfucker's big about six
two
so gorilla yeah yeah
big old Caucasian gorilla running around
what do they call them
vanilla gorilla
going to Silverbacks
yeah there you go yeah
then Ben said the bread is just as bad
as McDonald's it's sugar and salt yeah I
mean if you're getting a sandwich like I
said with all that bread on it then yeah
that's not great either so
and honestly I kind of feel like in a
lot of ways if you just go to McDonald's
if you don't get fries and [__] like
that if you just get like a couple of
burgers that'd probably be better
because they're smaller
you know the bread it's not as much
bread
I don't know I guess it depends what you
get you know but some of the stuff at
Subway is healthier but I don't I don't
hate Subway I don't let it go a lot of
people have like a hate on for Subway
because it's like the bread tastes weird
which it kind of does but um you know
their sandwiches aren't great there's
lots of better places to get sandwiches
like I said if I'm gonna get a sub I'm
gonna go to [__] Publix and get it so
because they're like a million times
better
I've had Subway if it was kind of the
only option and it's fine you know what
I mean depending on what you get but I
usually get something plain like I
usually get just like roast beef with
veggies on it Camp guys saying protein
is calories dense no it isn't go look at
Sugar go look at how calorie Dead sugar
is it's about [__] five times what
protein is I think [__] in a chicken
breast it's it's very it's almost all
protein but I think the calories is only
about what maybe 60 calories
they're 60 70 calories I think well it
depends on what size brush yeah just
like a standard you know just with by
the book
there's not much very not very many
protein not a lot of calories in it no I
think it's more calories than that but I
don't know how many it is often I think
it was under a hundred I remember it
correctly
Danny Rowling said McChickens are the
shiznit yeah I actually I quite like um
I quite like McDonald's chicken
sandwiches yeah it was talking about how
skinny people used to be and how fat
they are now
that crazy old dude I worked with a
[__] Electrolux [__] Jimmy he was
a million years old back then
he called it man I thought he was crazy
but he didn't think he was right he said
everybody got fat when they came out of
corn syrup
yeah so before that before that time
they were using cane sugar and he said
you could drink a 12 pack of Coca-Cola
every [__] day and not gain any
weight on it and it's as soon as soon as
it became came as soon as it became corn
syrup [__] everybody was getting fat
he said he saw it happen
well and the thing about it too is that
corn syrup now they put it in stuff that
you don't expect sweetener to be in yeah
like it's in everything I bet you corn
syrup is the most calorie dense out of
anything
we're way up there we're up there with
[__] Kryptonite and [__] uranium
Kryptonite his calorie dense who knew
yeah you're gonna get really fat on that
[__] yeah oh yeah that's why that's why
Look at stupid man
is that why is that is that why Superman
stayed away from it because he doesn't
want to get fast oh [__] [__] that
because he doesn't want to go yeah Tammy
says chicken breast has 165 calories per
three and a half ounces okay thank you
that's still not much
yeah I mean well that's why they always
tell you if you're on like you're trying
to eat healthy and stuff like chicken is
a good lean chicken turkey fish actually
fish is the best out of all of them yeah
go see what an equal amount of [__]
equal amount in terms of weight of sugar
yields and calories that's probably
[__] a thousand
well I well I suck down the thing of
orange juice and vodka oh well
I didn't eat much today though see I ate
less than Jared today too I had one
small that was egg salad right yeah no
no that was an egg salad it was tuna
salad oh tuna salad yeah uh tuna and egg
salad with a small tuna egg salad
sandwich when I came home and then for
lunch today I had a little can of
chicken salad
and a little thing of dried coconut
that's it that's all I had today so I
eat less than Jared
but yeah so
um 452 calories for white bread six
ounces of white bread yeah
yeah
anything whites is a white bread
anything white is high in calories yeah
that's what they always tell you bread
just rice potatoes yeah pasta that's
which is a shame because make you fat
because I love pasta and potatoes you
can still eat them you just have to like
eat any moderation yeah you know what I
mean you can eat anything I don't like
the whole thing where it's just kind of
like oh you can't eat that or that's a
bad food it's like you can eat stuff
that you like just not as often that's
all
because if you make yourself miserable
your whole entire life like you can't
ever eat stuff you like then that's not
anything there's somebody highly highly
processed flowers like you know make
white bread and
when your body goes to digest it
releases lots of sugars very quickly
it's easy to break down
so you get fat off of it if it's a more
brown bread course and like a
multi-grain but like some of that real
actually I heard that some of that real
crude bread that's like something that
you would get out of the Medieval Era
that's got you know I mean big pieces in
it and [__] I say that's actually uh
less fattening it's gotten more
nutrition yeah I've heard that's better
for you a lot better for you because it
releases that it releases it a lot more
slowly so your instantly can keep up
with it
brace versus said oh wow I just ordered
Subway for the first time in many years
and I see you streaming yeah that's a
coincidence uh Tammy said three ounces
of sugar has 329 calories okay
granther said the last guy I grant
they're put in prison before retiring
was a chest or molester dude was a music
teacher who diddled his students yeah
great that's great this dude I mean
holy [__] this [__] store like I knew
you know I knew Jared from Subway and
it's like I knew that he got caught for
you know uh Kitty prawns and uh we'll
call it that and um various other things
but I didn't know that he also kind of
had like an accomplice and I also didn't
know that several people had like tried
to report him over the years and kind of
nobody did much of anything about it so
there's that which is pretty special but
we'll get into all that
Camp guy said I love Publix Order ahead
submarine Sandwiches also they usually
only dress the sandwich with mayo and
mustard it stays dry and not soggy and I
put the Italian vinaigrette on at home
yeah that's what we do too like I always
get it on the side but yeah I mean I
I'll die on that Hill I mean Publix subs
are the [__] best they are so [__]
good
um Tammy said there's a bread brand
called Dave's Killer Bread that's really
good I don't think I've ever seen that
like can you get in the grocery store
because I've never seen it but yeah
Anthony said did you watch the video on
YouTube uh someone tried to eat just
broccoli for a week made it two days and
almost died
[Laughter]
it's not much nutrition well that's
right well there's not much calories for
sure like I said to get your to your
caloric uh you know thing you'd really
have to eat a lot of broccoli and it's
like nobody really wants to eat that
much broccoli why would you want to do
that to yourself I don't really know a
lot of people are taking in a lot of
excess calories through their drinks
fruit drinks sodas coffee because
they're adding [__] to the coffee and I
don't believe in all this sweet and low
and [__] sweet you know [__]
that's probably got calories in it too
like this is what zero calories well it
fools the test somehow but I bet your
body can't tell that from sugar
I just got a feeling you know but I
can't prove it
but I haven't noticed any weight loss
from people [__] drinking diet colas
yeah but the thing about it though is I
feel like a lot of people will do a
thing where it's like well I'm gonna get
two of the super-sized meals at
McDonald's but if I get Diet Coke it'll
cancel it out like I've seen people have
that sort of like mentality it's
probably better than corn syrup but I
bet you it's not that much better
saccharin and [__] it probably does the
same thing probably I heard somebody
else [__] argue that that it's a
chemical that fools the the test for
calories
but when that gets into your body your
body just responds to it it's like it
was sugar
brace versus that I worked at Subway for
years dude came in and asked for a
meatball Marina with monetary cheddar
a meatball Marina with monetary
Monterey somebody that doesn't know how
words work yeah
yeah monetary kid uh Ian England said
your body still makes insulin when you
eat zero calorie stuff yeah yeah
probably better in other words it sees
it as sugar like I said if you want to
have sugar you might as well just have
real sugar but just like not much of it
yeah you know what I mean the only thing
that I use is because I use sweet and
low I don't like Splenda as much like it
tastes weird to me but um I just have
those little sweet and low sugar packets
for my coffee but I don't usually make
coffee at home all that much anymore so
I'm not really all that worried about it
um we're gonna talk about bread still
Camp guy said I'm not really a big fan
of bread with a large number of
different whole grains and nuts embedded
in it I do like that actually yeah I
like real I like real dense like crunchy
bread sunflower seeds in it um although
I do like a good olive bread yeah okay
one of my favorite breads I kind of like
um anything that's like real thick and
dense I'm really into well like with
multi-green stuff on top like I said
Publix they're multigrain bread is
delightful I really really like their
multigrants you always putt plug in
Publix they better pay us
got to go to Publix today and we're
gonna pick up some sodas you wanted some
sodas yeah stuff like that yeah
all right so we're going to talk about
this [__] let's talk about it
let's talk about this [__] all
right so we'll start at like I said I
think most people you know here probably
know who Jared Fogle is he was a
spokesman for Subway for many many years
got super super famous and uh quite Rich
uh off of this and you know recognized
everywhere and then it turned out uh
surprise surprise he was a uh job
molester you know what I mean so that's
great
all right so but let's start at the very
beginning so Jerry Jared Fogle
uh he's actually five years younger than
me so he was born in 1977 in
Indianapolis Indiana
now apparently
um he was you know pretty normal kid and
everything like that but when he was
about in third fourth grade
uh you know right around the 80s at the
start of like the big video game boom he
got real real into video games and would
spend hours and hours on end playing
them when he got home and uh you know so
not exercising pretty much too so he
would just like sit in front of the
video games and play them and play them
and as he started doing that he also
started
um you know snacking and we're not
talking about just like little snack you
know I got like a little bag of Doritos
or something like that the kid would sit
there for hours playing video games and
would drink like cans and cans and cans
of soda whole bags Doritos like [__]
Pop-Tarts Cheetos cheese balls just
whatever like whatever they had in the
cookies whatever they had in the house
like he and he would just bring it all
like next to him
so that he didn't have to like get up
and like you know what I mean I just
wish I get that because I grew up in the
same era I would didn't really get into
video games but my brother did for sure
and man he would just like sit there and
play for hours and hours he didn't need
as much as this guy did though so this
guy is this kid is like just sitting
there just packing away snacks and not
moving around you know what I mean
basically whatever was in the house he
would [__] eat it
so he did this throughout his entire
childhood
to a point where when he was 19 years
old like he graduated from high school
and then he was going to
um college at 19 and by that time he
weighed
425 pounds
and they were estimating when he said
like how much he ate in a day and stuff
like that they were estimating that this
dude was eating 10
000 calories a day damn how the [__]
would you have time to eat 10th I can't
even imagine how much food that is it's
pathological Behavior man uh big time
Big Time you gotta go out of your way to
eat that much yeah I don't even how
would you even have time to eat that
much food
that's a lot of food we had the money I
mean I guess this was when he was a kid
like a teenager so I guess he was now I
wonder where his parents were just like
Jesus Christ you're [__] eating this
out of house and home I think his dad
was a doctor so I guess they had money
but
that was another thing too is like his
dad
he's he said like in interviews Jared
said later on that you know after he
went off to college like sometimes he
didn't want to like come back home and
visit his parents and stuff like that
because his dad was always negative
about how fat he was because his dad was
a doctor like not in a mean way but just
kind of like hey you might wanna
you know get get some of those pounds
off 425 pounds that's kind of a lot well
because by the time he went to college
he couldn't really I mean you weigh 425
pounds he can't really even just like
walk around and he said that a lot of
times he I think he was just like a
business management major or something
like that and a lot of times he would
just like pick his classes
by you know how close they were like how
easy they were to get to and how easy he
could park at them because it's like he
had to drive to them sometimes if they
were too far away and sometimes they had
that he had to like find places to park
where he could get out of the car
because he was so big that he like had a
hard time getting out of the car you
know what I mean because he was like
he was he was a big boy like I saw some
um you know documentaries about it and
they had like photos of him back then
and he was like a very very large a very
very large person
so he you know obviously having a lot of
uh problems with um you know he had some
friends and stuff but it's like a lot of
times he would be walking with them
around campus he couldn't keep up with
them because it's like you know he would
start breathing heavy and because you
know he could walk maybe like 500 feet
before he started like freaking out and
then he also started getting
um
uh edema like he had started like
swelling and the feed and legs and stuff
like that
and also because of his weight he also
developed um sleep apnea uh which is you
know a problem that a lot of overweight
people have and because of this like he
was waking up all the time so he was
always tired and at one point
um while he was in college he was
actually in a car wreck because he fell
asleep at the wheel because it was sleep
apnea and he hit a tree like I don't
know if he was hurt bad or anything like
that but it's probably all that fat like
[__] cushioning but um but that was I
I kind of heard like some sources said
that maybe that was like partly his
wake-up call like when he got in this
car accident because like his health was
so bad
um and I think he went to the doctor too
like about the edema and everything like
that and they were like look bro you
really need to lose some weight I mean
you're not gonna I think one of his
doctors told him that he wasn't gonna
probably wasn't gonna live like past 35
if he kept going on the way he went on
because it's not only was he eating 10
000 [__] calories a day which I don't
even know how you manage that but it's
like he was not
moving around at all like he could
barely walk you know what I mean
so they were like you just can't go on
like this right
so uh at that point he decided that he
was just going to completely
change his life
now the reason that Subway got involved
in this was because he lived in
off-campus housing at um I think it was
University of Indy Indiana uh
Bloomington
so he had an apartment and the apartment
building and I've seen pictures of it
was literally like right outside the
apartment building there was a Subway
like right there it looked like it was
in the same building actually it was
just kind of like the next building over
so Subway was right there now I don't
know what I'm sorry oh
I don't know because I've heard that he
had been eating at that Subway all the
time like previously to him starting the
diet but he would go in there and you
know eat 10 000 calories worth of [__]
you know what I mean so it's just like
hey give me three meatball subs or
whatever you know and cookies and soda
and everything like that
but because
um he was like well they have all these
other options too because they were
starting to plug their you know we have
what was it five subs or six Subs like
under five grams of fat or something
like that
but like I said that's that's
um uh you know it being under five or
six grams of fat that means you can't
have anything on it you can't have any
dressing on it you can't be cheese on it
can't be Mayo on it can't have anything
on it like that so technically if you
put anything on it it's gonna be over
that but yeah I always thought it was
funny how they're always trying to
sell all this [__] [__] lies and
Fantasies to fat people zero fat you can
eat it man eating fat doesn't make you
fat eat [__] carbs carbs makes you
fat
fat really is not usually not digested a
lot of times it's just passed out of
your bowels it can end up in your
bloodstream but it's more like kind of a
lubricant
for your food mostly
eating fat isn't making them fat
I mean it's the carbs okay here here's a
good example candy corn that's that's
zero fat
eat a bunch of that [__] see how much
weight you lose you ain't lose any
[__] weight
just funny
they just lie to people well I think
there was kind of a trend there's always
like Trends in diets yeah and I feel
like that was kind of the trend in the
90s
um in the 2000s where you know
everything had to be low fat but the
stupid thing is like if you take all the
fat out of something then usually they
would like cram it full of sugar so it
would still taste good and I'm like and
that's just as bad like you know and
that was like it's the same amount of
calories really you can say [__]
potatoes man [__] zero fat eat up you
know you'll lose weight no you won't
[__] pasta I kind of feel like the
thing about it though and I think
Jared's case is like indicative of this
I mean we'll get into like the [__] that
he did later on but this is kind of like
early days still
but the thing about it is that if you
eat
if you're in a calorie deficit you're
gonna lose weight and it doesn't matter
where those calories come from
necessarily because the thing about it
was that he's eaten 10 000 calories of
junk food
um you know prior to this and then when
he decides to go on his quote unquote
Subway diet
um you know and he goes to under 2 000
calories like I said he could have been
eating under 2 000 calories of chocolate
bars he still would have lost weight
because he wasn't eating 10 000 calories
anymore like it was was would that have
been healthy eating 2 000 calories of
chocolate of course not but I'm just
saying he probably still would have lost
weight especially at the weight that he
was at yeah because like you said it
takes a lot to maintain yeah that to
maintain that amount of weight right
gotta eat a lot yeah now going into a
caloric deficit yeah you'll lose weight
but unfortunately you're gonna lose
muscle before you lose fat the body will
burn that up first
so
I don't know it depends on depends on
the exact situation I wouldn't because
I'm on stuff that bolsters my [__]
metabolism I can't go catabolic
if you're on any kind of anabolic
steroids or testosterone or anything
you'll burn fat first because there's
too much [__] protein synthesis
happen happening is you can't go
catabolic you or it's harder a lot
harder but a person who is older
with a normal old person's metabolism
you go on calorie restriction your
muscle come off first you'll end up just
looking real loose and flabby no shape
so losing weight through calorie
deficit I never recommend it you lose
weight through
recomposition get in the gym build
muscle birth fat eat a lot
don't eat a little eat a lot but just
work out a lot lift a lot it ends up
working a lot better
the results
[__] starvation
it's very [__] risky
Jen can get away with it because she's
her her system's bolstered with uh
[__] anabolics too slightly just at
therapeutic levels so she can go on a
low calorie diet and not lose fat or not
lose muscle I am but for some reason I'm
a weird person and it's just like my
metabolism is jacked and it's just kind
of like I'm really not built to eat very
much yeah and she's got real good
anti-aging genes her mom still looks
young
yeah and Jen's in her 50s she doesn't
look like she's in her 50s if I put her
next time if I put her next to women
that look who are in their 50s she just
doesn't even resemble them
there's just a lot about her that just
does not look like a 50 year old woman
now there are a lot of those out there
but there you can tell them they're
night and day apart from the average
woman I see guys who are my age I just
can't [__] believe it they got the
old man walking everything they look
like they're in the 70s
not everybody's agent at the same rate
I was reading something about that the
other day because they were talking
about not modern day but talking about
um back in the 70s and 80s how much
older everybody looked back then and
they were talking about some actors you
know that Wilford Brimley you know the
uh diabetes
um yeah diabetes diabetes yeah um do you
know that yeah yeah yeah well he was in
that movie Cocoon in the 80s do you
realize he was playing like a 70 odd
year old man he was only 51. when he was
in that movie I'm older than that but
like I don't know if they but yeah
that's like my age and I was just like
oh my God I look like an old man yeah
but he he was playing like 20 years
older but he looked and I was like
that's [__] crazy I would have never
thought that yeah but
that's crazy
but yeah I'm just I don't know so but
I'm just saying that it that somebody
like Jared that was morbidly obese I
mean 425 pounds I'm not actually sure
how tall he is I think he's just like
average I didn't seem like super tall or
anything but being 425 pounds eating 10
000 calories a day to maintain that 425
pounds and like not moving or walking or
anything like that
um you know if you suddenly go to
1800 calories a day yeah that way it's
going to come right off you money
a friend of mine was looking to get
hired after the Jared debacle they said
any acknowledgment of him is grounds for
immediate dismissal damn messed up
yeah I mean they were disowned his ass
well you can't blame him and the thing
about it too and allegedly allegedly
allegedly
um Jared's Behavior had been reported to
Subway higher ups as early as I believe
2008 but they didn't really do anything
about it you know what I mean but to be
fair law enforcement didn't really do
much of anything about it either not
until many many years had gone by so you
know what I mean but we'll get into that
so so he starts going to this Subway
that's he said it was literally quote
unquote literally 10 steps from his
apartment
so you know that's that's good he can be
on a diet and be lazy at the same time
it's only like a 10. it's only like 10
steps away so it was yeah it was like
right there so he goes there and he
starts ordering the same thing every day
like he would skip breakfast he would
just have a cup of coffee or something
like that
and then for lunch he would have half of
a like a six inch turkey sub no cheese
no mayo no nothing like that just turkey
and veggies
and then like a little bag you know they
have this little bag of like baked lays
or whatever the [__] so I think it was
baked lays actually and then a Diet Coke
and then for dinner he would get a 12
inch veggie sub again no mayo no cheese
no nothing like that and I don't know if
he had another potato chips or anything
like that the ultimate potato chip is a
[__] Pringle because you know that
they're giving you [__] fried instant
mashed potatoes
yeah yeah some of the flavors are like
really some of them are weird but I've
gotten like I got one a couple years
back at Christmas time they had ones
that were um uh peppermint stick yeah
and they were weird but they were pretty
good thank you thank you murder Hornet
thank you he says eat fresh
I mean Pringles definitely do not taste
like potato chips it doesn't say potato
chip anywhere on the [__] box or on
the top anymore it says it's a pringle
it's it's not it's its own thing it's
its own thing but that's cool they got
him candy flavored and everything heard
it in Japan they got a [__] chocolate
flavored and wasabi food actually if you
go to Fye yeah in the mall they because
you know how they have all the Japanese
uh they have that big section of like
Japanese snacks and stuff like Pocky and
everything
um sometimes I have seen like the weird
Japanese Pringles flavors there so
sometimes they do and the weird
strawberries and the weird KitKat
flavors and stuff like that they have
all of that
uh Jeff yard said the whole thing is
crazy Jenny we also mention Jared's
accomplice Russell Taylor oh yeah we're
gonna talk about that [__] well
he's kind of like just so weird to me
because Russell Taylor like I said I
didn't even know before I started
researching this that he had like an
accomplice in this whole [__] [__]
show
um and Russell Taylor kind of the reason
he got caught
um but also I don't know I feel like
Russell Taylor ended up doing like way
more prison time than Jared and I'm not
really well I mean I know why but I
don't know it just seems like really
weird to me but yeah we'll get into that
we'll get into that so um so yeah so he
switches to this diet and that's what he
ate like pretty much every day and I
guess like the people that worked at the
subway like confirmed it yeah the
motherfucker's in here every day and he
eats the exact same thing they always
had it ready for him and all that kind
of shape so he over the course of one
year
one year with this diet and he also
started walking too like which he hadn't
been doing before he'd just been sitting
around his back
so over the course of one year from 1998
to 1999
um he lost
245 pounds which is amazing that's like
several people's worth of weight that he
lost
so after this what ended up happening
was that he had a form of like a former
roommate of his at college
ended up being a writer for the student
newspaper at the University of Indiana
and he passed Jared one day and didn't
realize it was like he didn't recognize
him because he hadn't seen him for a
while because he had lost so much weight
like he went down to like 180 pounds
right like from 425 so he was like
unrecognizable
so the guys like walking passing he's
like holy [__] Jared what the [__]
happened to you and he just said yeah I
went on the Subway diet and it's like
you know I lost all this weight and it's
awesome and now he can like do all this
stuff that he couldn't do before like he
can actually walk around and like have a
life and [__] like that which he hadn't
been able to do obviously
so the guy was like
um he wrote
um like a story like a cover story for
the student newspaper I think it was
called something like from thick to thin
or through thick and thin or something
like that
um so he wrote this story about Jared
and his crazy diet
um and how he lost all this weight and
it was like super inspirational and all
that
so it turned out that this uh article
that was in the student newspaper
it turned up right around the time that
somebody that was like a kind of a big
National writer that was writing for
Men's Health Magazine was working on an
article about and I think it was called
stupid diets that work
and he heard about this kid in
Indianapolis who had lost 245 pounds by
eating Subway and he's like oh I need to
get in on that so he called him up he's
I think he couldn't get permission to
like use his name at first so he just
like used a pseudonym
but he wrote about it and there was like
um a big article in men's health about
it so you know that's a big magazine
like in National magazine so a lot of
people saw that and got you know that
got a lot of attention
so obviously because this got a lot of
attention it got back to subway
Executives because in the article Jared
actually credited Subway with
essentially saving his life
even though like I said it wasn't Subway
specifically that caused him to lose the
weight it was just the fact that he made
the decision to eat
you know 8 000 calories he had been
eating before that's a good way like I
said you eat 8 000 calories less of
anything you're gonna lose weight
because you're not gonna be able to
maintain that large size body anymore so
you know so like I said it wasn't Subway
specifically that did it yeah but Subway
knew uh a good marketing campaign when
they saw one and um and it actually did
end up man it works like gangbusters
that [__] [__] was everywhere I
remember the commercials being
everywhere they just thought it was late
90s but I was wrong no it's two thousand
so yeah the first commercial aired in
2000 and that was in like a local market
because they wanted to test it out they
reached out to Jared and they initially
didn't ask they just said hey would you
want to do like a local commercial like
talking about your weight loss and how
Subway saved your life and all it's like
talk about your diet and how you did it
and all this other stuff
yeah so he said of course he would
so January 1st 2000 they did kind of one
in sort of like a local market to test
it out and this first test commercial
was really successful because the thing
about it and the thing that the ad
Executives
um you know picked up on right away was
that Jared was he was just this nobody
he wasn't anybody special he was just
this schlubby guy next door type dude
you know what I mean he didn't he wasn't
glamorous he wasn't attractive he wasn't
anything like that but he had like he
was just a regular guy who had an
extraordinary story like I said no you
know he actually did lose all that
weight which you know that's something
that a lot of people want to do and they
can relate to somebody that that did it
the way he did it now
you know the thing about it is that
Subway was pushing very hard like to say
it's like oh the subway died but they
have to put all the legalese like in the
commercial which they always did it's
like hey it worked for Jared but you
know they didn't say he went on a
starvation diet even though he
essentially did but they're like you
know consult your doctor before you know
this stuff blah blah but it worked for
him
um you know they made sure to mention
that he was exercising as well like he
was also walking and stuff which he
hadn't been doing before so that also
made a difference but that's I mean
that's the thing so they're gonna like
make it seem like it was Subway that did
it and this was so successful
that I mean Subway the first year which
was 2000 that they started doing the
Jared ads because they ended up doing I
think they ended up doing like over the
course of The Campaign which was really
really long like several years more than
a decade
um I think they did like more than 300
commercials with him and he also like
toured the country and we'll get into
that too but they did a bunch of
commercials with them during the first
year that they did the commercials with
Jared with the weight loss and you know
him showing his big pants which were 60
inches his pants were 60 inches and
that's what like very very famously like
every time he would do
um you know a TV appearance or whatever
he would always hold up those [__]
pants and I don't even know what
happened to those pants but yeah they
were 60 inches and then he had gone down
to like a 34 inch waist so if he held up
the pants like it looked like he could
fit in one well he probably could fit in
one leg now I'm thinking about it
because he was very big on saying oh not
only are they 60 inches they're also the
relaxed fit you know what I mean he said
that like a bunch of times but yeah
so it was so successful that I think
Subways uh profits went up 18 in the
first year that they started doing it
and then 16 subsequently so
um so it was a hugely successful
campaign like I said particularly in
regards to weight loss Americans really
really like
quick fixes they like something that
sounds easy it's like what you know can
I do that and so the thing about it was
that even though it wasn't Subway
sandwiches specifically that caused him
to lose weight it was the calorie
deficit but the fact that he said that
it was so easy I just have half a turkey
sub for lunch and like you know a veggie
sub for dinner and it's like I lost all
this weight everybody's thinking well
that normal schlub can do that I can do
that too that's easy you know what I
mean and I'll lose weight also well like
I said that's you know it's dumb but
that's kind of like a lot of a lot of
Americans want that they don't they
don't really want to have to like
work for anything or you know what I
mean like especially especially weight
loss because it's hard so it's like well
they don't really want to do anything
it's hard yeah
the food industry they're not going to
tell you all the truth I mean to tell
you the truth about the dieting and
[__] how the body works and
everything they would end up losing a
lot of money look at the old food
pyramid they had back then
the big stuff at the bottom was all the
grains and the cereal and then the
vegetables and then the meat at the very
top
eating all those grains of cereals and
they were just trying to sell you what
they had in proportions of what they had
a healthy diet that it'd be a lot better
if that try that was swept over yeah I
mean maybe you should probably have a
bunch of Meat and Fish you should
probably have the most vegetables and
then Meat and Fish that way I heard it
was Meat and Fish because it's [__]
protein and then the vegetables and a
little bit of grains so that'd be a lot
better for you yeah because and that's
what animals eat
and other animals they're eating fish
and look at a bear
we live we evolve to be a lot like a
bear or a dog eating at a trash can yeah
it was like a pack animal walking around
most of the time
uh getting fish out of the water and
[__] eating little animals and birds
and [__] grabbing a [__] deer and
this and vegetables because they're
growing you know but then they didn't
have
bread
that's that's from a much later era
that's from agriculture
they were just eating meat vegetables
they really weren't eating bread nuts
that's maybe what
that started maybe 20 000 years ago
fifteen thousand years ago that's not
that's nothing in evolutionary time
but mostly meat that's what caused us to
get big big brain capacity and stuff
that's my chimps don't have big brains
you don't get enough meat
well I read
um I read a couple of books where they
were talking about the theory that
probably when we learned to cook meat
yeah was when the brain started getting
much larger because you can eat more but
you can chew more of it and you get
better nutrition out of it yeah because
your digestive system really can't it
was a pretty compelling case if I
remember yeah it's been a while you know
they're talking about red meat though
it probably wouldn't be this it wouldn't
be the case with fish that's probably
easily digestible raw yeah yeah he was
talking about yeah bread meat talking
about red yeah mostly
um
you can unlock a lot more of the
nutrition
Mississippi in my background
seeing how Generations before me and my
grandparents Generations live they live
near water where it was easy to fish
and it's probably been that way since
the dawn of time the the best way to get
meat is to [__] trap it fish fish
that's a easy meal if you've got a line
and a hook you can [__] eat all day
long if you've got a [__] fish trap
you just make it out of sticks stick
them in the [__] shallow water and
chase them into the [__] basically a
pen or Corral and then shut it and go in
there and get all the fish
you know that's an easy meat a lot
easier than running down a damn deer
you know
so
I kind of think
human brain size started to [__] get
bigger when they were fishing it's more
likely I think fishing
because even if that happened in Africa
there's a lot of places to fish in
Africa too
get your ass eaten by an alligator by
alligators though crocodile
or hippos hippos
because hippos are [__] this whole
Out of Africa thing yeah it might have
come out of Africa Homo sapiens but a
lot of it probably happened in Asia too
that's another thing and up in Asia
there have been a lot of places to fish
okay that's it
all right so yeah
um so the campaign with Jared was
initially so successful as I said that
their Subway's revenues like uh
increased exponentially not only that
I've heard that so many people started
doing like the quote-unquote Subway diet
that uh at some locations they started
running out of turkey you know what I
mean because everybody was getting yeah
because that became like their most
popular so because which is just goes to
show like just one thing well it's just
weird how one thing will just hit at a
certain time and everybody just jumps on
board with that it's like so bizarre but
I remember him being like super famous
like overnight which is crazy he was
even as he was on Saturday Night Live
they did a whole show on South Park they
did all that remember that did you see
um what's it called Jared has AIDS
yeah yeah you remember that one the guy
brought up a good thing he said there's
a theory that ingestion natural
hallucinogens might have jump started
conscious yeah I heard about it that
actually there was somebody on one of
them down TED Talks that I heard a long
time ago he made a real compelling
argument for that
human beings and other animals being
forced to eat
plants and [__] and food sources they
wouldn't normally be be eaten because
they're forced out by migration and
they're tripping out on stuff
uh having mind expansion and that that
might fuel Consciousness in in humans it
might have possibly
getting high
yeah that that uh does make a lot of
sense caused him to come to come to
certain conclusions where they can um
solve problems and then they're
surviving and they're and the other
humans are humanoids that were doing
this weren't surviving because they
weren't tripping out and coming up with
Solutions
okay so uh so because this was uh such a
successful campaign Subway offered Jared
a contract
um and basically giving him over a
million dollars a year
to star in their commercials like do a
series of commercials and also go around
making like public appearances so he
would go and like when a new Subway was
opening like he would show up at the
[__] and do that kind of stuff and just
any kind of like events that they had
scheduled like
at the corporate level like he would
show up and the thing about it was he
would always give speeches about health
and about
um you know obesity and things like that
which you know he wasn't a nutritionist
he wasn't a dietitian he wasn't a doctor
he wasn't he didn't know any of that
stuff he was just like a schlub that
decided he was gonna
stop eating so much and lose some weight
and it worked and so now suddenly he was
an authority on stuff that really he
wasn't an authority of but okay so but
like I said people responded to him
because like I said he was like an every
man and I think that people were like oh
well if he did it then I can do it so I
think that's why people responded so
well because like I said if you see the
commercials because I was watching some
of the commercials a lot of them were on
YouTube and um he doesn't come across he
comes across as like schlubby like I
said he's just like a very awkward like
average I mean you know watching them
now it's kind of hard to like separate
yourself because you know what a scumbag
he is
but back then everyone just saw him as
like kind of oh he's just like this
regular guy and it was like kind of
endearing because he was like a little
bit awkward you know what I mean so I
think that's what people responded to
maybe
so so he's making over a million dollars
a year suddenly keep in mind at this
point he's only just out of college he's
only 22. now he did um he did have a job
like lined up it was like an airline or
something like that but I think he
worked for added for a little while or
he didn't even bother because you know
Subway came knocking and you know who's
gonna say no to like a million dollars a
year nobody I wouldn't that's for sure
so yeah he's like okay well I'm gonna
get on that
so right around this time too
um you have to think that because Jared
was so obese like during his whole
entire uh you know childhood and his
college Years and everything like that
um he'd never really had a girlfriend or
anything but uh he actually did start
dating after he lost all the weight
and he actually did start dating this
woman who was uh she had also graduated
from uh the same College as him and uh
they ended up getting married and she
was actually even in some of the ads I
think like because like I said the ad
started in 2000 I think like a year
later like when right around the time
they were getting married like um you
know that she was in some of the ads as
well and he started like touring the
country like I said giving speeches and
you know appearing at Subway openings
and crap like that
so he does this for
um several years
until I believe it was 2004.
and then he decides that he's going to
help children in America fight obesity
because he's like well I want to um yeah
this is gonna sound bad when I say it
because like I said everybody knows what
he did now but it's like he wanted to
Target kids right around third fourth
grade because that was the age he was
when he first started like you know
gaining weight
and so he's like so I want to get to
them before you know before they
establish bad habits and start eating
too much and like end up in the position
that I was in so he decides he's going
to start the Jared Foundation
which was you know just a you know a
non-profit to uh fight childhood obesity
so he set that up and he was like taking
donations and stuff and he would go
around like I said and give talks at
schools and things like that and the the
logo of it was even the the a was like
the big pants you know the big famous
big pants that he was holding up did you
hear that I said they were 60 inches man
yeah he held him up like all the time
they were like they were like twice as
big as him like he could fit in one leg
you know what I mean remember Jacobs
yeah I think of Jenkins yeah yeah it was
just like wearing Jacobs yeah I mean
yeah Jenkins were pretty ridiculously
big too but not the waste like the waist
was tight the waist was little just that
each pant leg was like a skirt well
that's what I mean I just kind of feel
like to me jankos were kind of like
dudes want to wear skirts but they want
to like seem like they're not wearing a
skirt I only remember girls wearing
jankos I know guys wore them but I
thought I saw guys wearing them they
remember the girls
they look good on on skinny [__] girls
raver girls they have to be [__] they
have to be [__] okay if you're not
[__] you shouldn't be wearing jinkos
every [__] girl I knew the wore those
was [__] ready to go
yeah back in those days
well there's there's also well there's
there's room for two in those pants
that's why my ex-sister-in-law wore them
yeah yeah and she was she was a stripper
and a [__] yeah she was great though she
was a good [__] yeah yeah I didn't get
it I was gonna that was my next question
yeah I heard all about it you heard all
of it I saw it too [__] um she'd go
out and [__] um sunbathe in the
backyard [__] just in full view
because she didn't care she was a
stripper
she had big old implants and everything
yeah yeah she was hot super hot
yeah okay yeah my sister-in-law she's
[__] crazy walking around naked
yeah
Jeffy art said he used to stuff the kids
in those pants while on tour are so
cringe given hindsight I mean so many
there because he toured so much with his
quote unquote Foundation which uh you
know surprise surprise turned out to be
a scam later on but um so there's so
many photos of him surrounded by
children uh that it's really really
disturbing because he was just like oh
going all over the country and going to
middle schools and elementary schools
and like talking and they all just
thought he was the [__] yes sir okay
yeah they all just thought he was the
[__] and it's I mean nobody knew back
then so I turned a brown shirt as my
ex-wife in the goth outfit
all right just let you guys know so I'm
not making it well thank you not making
it oh wait another picture
yeah that's what she looked like when
she wore jacos
except those aren't Jake they're not
jankos but that's her
that was a few years later that's what
I'm talking about
yeah she walk around naked okay
so yeah so he's going all around with
his quote-unquote foundation uh speaking
at middle schools and bloody blah and uh
so that's the thing now it ended up they
found out later on that the Jared
Foundation
I think over the course of its existence
they raised
somewhere in the neighborhood of 650 000
700 000 or something like that
um probably only a hundred thousand of
that went to anything and even remotely
having to do with childhood obesity I
don't even know about that and like a
lot of it um they don't know what
happened to it so
um I know what probably happened to it
it probably just went up right up
Jared's nose or he used it to pay
strippers that's probably what happened
but uh yeah we'll get into that so yeah
the Jared Foundation uh turned out to be
crap but the thing about it is that it
caused it allowed him to get into
schools where there were kids and he
could interact with kids all the time
now here's some that I didn't really no
one really addressed this to any great
extent I guess because nobody really
knows
um you know unless you're Jared you
don't really know her unless you're
somebody that knows him but the thing
about it is that how long was Jared
if you know into kids let's put it like
that because as far as I could determine
from my research which admittedly was
you know limited it's only like over a
couple of days and stuff but
you know he didn't really get in trouble
for anything like that
prior to
um
prior to him getting caught like later
on with you know what I mean so I don't
really know if this was just something
that
was kind of in the back of his mind the
whole time but he never acted on it
until he could until he was kind of
given license
because I don't think that it just kind
of like came on him suddenly oh I you
know suddenly I'm gonna be like a
[__]
crocodile
a pedometer you know what I mean it's
I don't think that just like occurs to
somebody spontaneously
that must have been some kind of like
secret fantasy he had from growing up
but like because he was you know really
really heavy like as and he didn't
really get a chance to act out on it and
then like later on when he had all this
money and he had kind of got license
like he was like [__] it I'm just gonna
do whatever I want I kind of maybe got
that feeling but I think that he always
had those proclivities because that's
like I said that's not usually something
that comes out of nowhere
people just don't suddenly decide when
they're older that they're into kids you
know what I'm saying I kind of feel like
that's sort of a deep-seated thing but
nobody really I mean I saw a couple
people that you know documentaries that
kind of mentioned that but I guess
there's really no way of knowing unless
you're him saying out of me
so so what happened so he establishes
this foundation and he starts you know
raking in all these donations and Stuff
Plus like at the same time he's still
being the subway spokesman so he's
breaking in money from that as well so
he's doing pretty good for himself like
he's essentially now a multi-millionaire
and so
um I guess too because he had spent his
entire teenage years in childhood and
college Years being really heavy and not
being able to do anything that quote
unquote normal people would do he as
soon as he lost all that weight and got
all that money he just went [__] buck
wild man he just like went out like he
got married like he had a wife and
everything but pretty much within a year
or two of him getting married he was
just [__] around all over the place
like he was having like long-term
Affairs every time that he would go to a
new city he would like look up on
Craigslist and get some escorts
um I heard that he was spending like
thousands and thousands of dollars a
year just like on escorts and strip
clubs and all this kind of stuff so
so he just went crazy I feel like as
soon as he got the money and the license
to do so he lost all that weight but I
wonder what he looked like
he must have had a lot of skin hanging
did he did he get did he get a bunch of
tucks
I don't know
why oh you messed up the lighting I
didn't do it yeah you did she blaming me
well you were the one that was holding
stuff up to the camera okay that's why
there you go it doesn't do it on its own
it does it when you hold stuff up to the
camera that's like bright you know what
I mean
um but yeah so he just starts [__]
showing everybody Lindsay that they're
going yeah she does look like a [__]
yeah she was a good [__] though she was
like the top number one stripper but
that's not the wrong one yeah she has
socks that says [__] on them that was
the first when I first met her she had
socks
that says [__] on him yeah they were
knee socks man they had the three
stripes on the knee socks and in the
center stripe is broken it says [__]
cute she was like the top stripper of
[__] Biloxi back in the back in the
late 90s uh remember what strip club she
worked at
but she made like fifteen hundred
dollars a week in Mississippi that's
like a [__] millionaire she had a lot
of money
and um
my ex's family was typical Southern
family they lived on a compound they'd
buy a five acres and they just build
houses on for the whole family on those
five acres
well we were the goth couple me and my
my ex and she was Raver
so she hung out with us
and so to like she'd have to get a tan
for work she didn't want to go around
the other houses you know and have like
you know other brother-in-laws and
[__] uncles and [__] looking at her
so she'd come behind our house and
[__] get a suntan
you know but she'd walk into the house
at the back door too [__] because she
was she worked naked so she didn't think
anything of it she just come in bikini
bottom bottom
[__] beautiful [__] implants and
[__] but you got used to it you got real
used to seeing her like that it didn't
it was her job
and her boyfriend was like uh
real good looking bodybuilder his name
was Tom also he was a friend of mine
and um
you know
he's on anabolics and [__] big dude
he was a stripper also he was a male
stripper
he ended up buying a
strip club here in
um Miami remember I told you about that
you know you strip club down in Miami he
offered me a job down there and man I'm
moving to [__] Miami because I need
somebody to keep to keep an eye on all
these women
foreign
yeah I don't know what was happening
down there but
they need to be policed
so I'm thinking bad [__] was happening
anyway that's it that's the story there
thank you okay uh send your six is
asking uh about Jared being on drugs uh
yeah as far as I know um yeah he was
doing all the drugs too so like I said
he just went [__] crazy he was
because he's 22 years old he's just out
of college he's a millionaire
um he just lost all this weight and is
probably you know doing a bunch of stuff
that he didn't get to do when he was a
teenager so he's probably like [__]
trying to live his best life if that I
mean that from his point of view you
know I mean so yeah um like I said he
got married but immediately started he
didn't only cheat on his web because he
had like long-term Affairs like with
several women like many women came
forward and said yeah I was sleeping
with him for like years and years so he
had like long-term relationships with
other women but he also whenever he was
on tour with the Jared Foundation like
he would call ahead to like the cities
and like he got most of the escorts off
Craigslist
um you know so he would call them up and
like set [__] up you know what I mean
and so they then he would go like he
would go and talk at the middle school
or whatever about hey you know don't get
fat
um you know exercise and eat a good diet
and then he's like hey let's go to the
strip club like he didn't say that to
kids but um although it wouldn't
surprise me if he did because that's the
thing about Jared gonna say
um not the sharpest tool in the shed
because once he got to a certain point
it almost seemed like he didn't
it didn't occur to him that he couldn't
just like say [__] out loud
you know what I mean because he would
say [__] to people like hey that middle
schooler is hot or whatever and it's
just like it didn't occur to him that
somebody might like find that
problematic and like might turn his ass
in like so he was pretty Brazen I think
he got to a point where he just thought
he could just get away with anything
because he got so much success so
quickly
after uh you know having been
um you know so
lonesome and sequestered and stuff like
that like during his childhood in his
teenage years I kind of feel like he
just went [__] nuts you know what I
mean like all this money and all this
you know he wasn't good looking but you
know if you went from 425 pounds to 180
pounds and you were just like a normal
looking dude and had millions of dollars
and you could probably just like do what
you wanted then yeah that's gonna go to
your head and it went to his head big
time Big Time
so yeah so he starts having all these
affairs
and go into hookers and you know trying
to he'd go to strip clubs and be like
hey I'll pay you fifty thousand dollars
if you'll come back to my hotel room and
[__] it's just crazy he was doing all
that kind of [__]
now one of the women that he got
involved with like long term was this
woman that he met her name was uh
Rachelle Herman walrond
and she was like a radio host I think
they met at some because she was there
like at some school that he was talking
at like she was there covering it or
something like that and they met in 2007
and they started uh you know having a
sexual relationship and this was in
Sarasota I think in Florida
so um and around this time too I think
like around 2007 2008 uh his first wife
um filed for divorce now in this first
filing I don't think they made this
super super public because I don't think
Subway obviously wanted anybody to know
because he was like their Golden Boy
like I said he was making them a lot of
money because the campaign was so
successful
but his first wife alleged that he was
um very controlling and uh abusive uh
emotionally abusive and things like that
which considering the [__] that came to
light later does not surprise me one
little bit
so you know what I mean so yeah she got
the [__] out of there
now um
so basically what happens to that so he
starts seeing Rochelle this woman who's
the radio host who that he had started
an affair with
and he while he was having a
relationship with her he also started
another relationship with this other
woman named Kathleen McLaughlin
um and he ended up I think he ended up
marrying her so that was like his second
wife now he eventually ended up having
two kids which is horrifying knowing
like what he did like later on but he
did actually have two kids of his own so
what the [__] there's like no [__]
excuse
Kathleen was actually a teacher I think
she was um was she a middle school
teacher I think she was a special ed
teacher Maybe
but yeah so um she kind of fell for his
shtick a lot of people did though
um because when he was in the
commercials and when he was at his
appearances and stuff like that like I
said he came across as like a little bit
awkward but like lovably awkward like in
every man type of dude but then like
behind the what you get the drink oh but
then like behind the scenes
um people are talking about how like
what a dick he was you know I mean like
he was just a [__] jerk and and he
would just like talk about really really
inappropriate [__] like and not
seem to really care about it like you
know what I mean it's just like he
seemed like yeah yeah like he could say
anything no which is crazy so like the
[__] that he said out loud was like
look it's crazy
so yeah so he ends up marrying
uh Kathleen I believe
now around this time too uh while he was
doing all of these speaking tours with
the Jared Foundation
this was also around the time that he
met uh the guy that would end up being
his partner in crime and this
motherfucker's name was Russell Taylor
now at the time that he met Russell
Taylor Russell Taylor was working for I
think the American Heart Foundation of
American Heart Foundation American Heart
Association whatever it is
so he was working for that like as their
youth projects coordinator so like
whenever they were doing like youth
programs or whatever like he would
coordinate that obviously that was like
his job
so the two of them met they were both
there like doing some kind of like you
know children's health program like it's
a middle school or something and Jared
was supposed to give a speech and uh
Russell helped him write it or helped
him punch it up or whatever and so the
two of them kind of hit it off and they
went out and had dinner and started
talking and they discovered that they
had a lot in common so they kind of you
know became friends and eventually
Russell Taylor would kind of become
Jared's kind of like right-hand man you
know what I mean
so um what ends up happening there is
that
they would
I guess they both um had an interest in
they were both like [__] hyper
hypersexual so they would both had an
interest in hey as soon as we talked to
these middle school kids about not
getting fat let's go hit the strip club
and see if we can get that stripper to
come back to the hotel with us and have
group sex with us you know what I mean
so it was that kind of [__]
so they started doing that
um and they also started uh drinking a
lot like really really the good [__]
because you know like I said Jared could
afford it
um drugs pretty much uh all the drugs
like everything you can imagine like as
far as like a big [__] party
lifestyle would uh entail
now so yeah
so the two of them it just seemed like
they wore into the same kind of [__]
like I said and Russell Taylor
was into some [__] weird [__] too so
we'll we'll get into that in a second
so after they had been hanging out for a
while and discovered all of these uh
proclivities that they had in common
Jared says to Russell hey why don't I
make you the director of the Jared
foundation and then that way we can both
tour the country together and
you know we could we can go to every
city and uh you know hit the strip clubs
get some hookers uh hang out with miners
you know that kind of [__]
also we can travel around the world and
do some uh you know
sex sex tourism sex tourism
uh so yeah the two of them did that as
well hey let's go to Thailand so we can
have sex with underage girls they would
do that kind of [__] too
and they bragged about it later on which
you know great so yeah they'd go because
you know
you guys know there are some countries
in the world where
you you guys yeah although I think there
is an age limit there it's just that
they're not enforcing it well yeah I
mean that amounts to the same thing yeah
pretty much the cops are in on it too
yeah like the vice cops are taking
bribes
that would make sense yeah
because that's I mean I hate to say but
it's like a huge Global industry like a
lot of [__] perverts will fly out
there and pay all kind of money some
cultures don't have that underage thing
they just don't have it I don't even I
don't think in Indonesia and certain
certain places where Islam is I don't I
don't think you know they're like well
if she's if she's fertile she's had her
period Then you can marry her yeah
that's good to go
they don't really have another age now
if she's a child probably not gross you
know they're going to come after you but
evidently in in Afghanistan they're
after little boys
so uh
I don't know but this is all local
cultures my my buddy Saad who lives in
Saudi Arabia he'd be he'd be pissed if I
brought up [__] Afghanistan because
he's like that's not us you know there
are those those cultures are all totally
different they just have a common
religion but their interpretation of
it's very different and their cultures
are different wherever they are a lot of
it has to do with very [__]
education and their income
Robert kitchen said dude had money he
could get women he's just a creep yeah
that's the thing here's the thing that
pisses me well I mean among them
everything pisses me off about Jared
Fogel but the thing about it is that
this [__]
he was just out of college he was 22.
like he did an amazing thing like he
lost 245 pounds okay amazing astounding
like a lot of people you know that
that's admirable okay but he did that
Subway comes call and said we'll give
you a million [__] dollars a year
just to go around and talk about Subway
and how you lost all this weight easy
easy money
and that had he just done that
he would still be around today and he
would still be beloved and everybody hey
remember that Jared wasn't he something
you know what I mean people be talking
about that but like he just couldn't
I don't understand people that just they
just can't help it they can't help not
being douchebags it's like it seems very
easy for someone like me to like not
being a douchebag but it's like for some
people it seems very difficult and for
for him it was very difficult all he had
to do was not do that like no one would
even care that much I wouldn't care that
much if all he did was you know it's not
great but if all he did was [__] around
his wife again not great but you know
and go to strip clubs and stuff that's
not illegal
um you know what I mean as long as
everyone's over 18 and everyone's
consenting
um you know like I said it's not super
admirable but whatever it's not illegal
I don't really care about it but the
fact that he was so dead set on
you know he could he did all that but
then it was just like he wanted to push
it further and further and he's just
like just going younger and younger and
younger and was so blatant about it
because I guess he just thought he could
get away with it I was like he and the
fact that he just like ruined his whole
entire like what would have been a very
very easy life just over something that
was just so
so you didn't have to do it like why
would you do that it just seems like a
really easy thing to avoid you know what
I mean very easy
especially because like I said he seemed
to have no problem
hiring escorts and stuff like that which
like I said as long as they're all over
18. I don't have a problem with that
there's you know I don't have a problem
with that
but
as long as ever like I said as long as
everyone's consenting as long as I'm
rapist or nothing like that but it's
just kind of like why
why go after kids we just you could have
just not done that damn and he would
have still been a million you used to
spawn walk around free you know what I
mean stupid and that's the thing like it
you know in his court cases like he
called it a stupid mistake I'm like
that's a little bit more than a stupid
mistake sorry he was into that [__] like
I said we'll get into like the [__] that
happened okay
so so yeah so him and Russell 2p is in a
pod right they're going around uh you
know to all the strip clubs drinking
doing all the drugs and everything like
that
and so basically and they're staying in
like super hot five star accommodation
all this kind of stuff like I said he
had millions of dollars so they were
living high on the hog you know what I
mean
now Russell at about this time period
because of all the drugs that Russell
was doing
he started getting uh paranoid that
someone was stealing money from the
foundation right because he was the one
that was the director even though I'm
pretty sure the foundation was just
there like to line Jared's Pockets but
whatever allegedly
so Russell decides I'm gonna find out
who's stealing all the money I'm like
it's probably spoiler alert it's
probably you but um he decides he's
gonna put cameras
all around the um like his house and the
offices and everything like that
so the cameras happened to catch
there was a teenage girl who worked at
the foundation like as an intern or
something like that
and the cameras happened to catch her
and her boyfriend sneaking into the
office and having sex
so Russell says to Jared hey we caught
like one of the employees like her and
her boyfriend were [__] in the thing
and we caught it on camera Jared was not
mad he's like I want to see that [__]
and he wanted to see that [__]
so um so yeah and so he sees it and
apparently and like I said she was 16 15
16 something like that
he liked it so much that he says to
Russell hey maybe we should install more
cameras around this place and like see
what else we can get so you know
um and then as it went on see the camera
no they're hidden okay they were like in
they were like little bitty like spy
cameras and [__] like that like they
were secret ones all right you know what
I mean they weren't just hanging out
because he put them around their like
secretly like so he could catch people
because he thought people were stealing
from him or whatever
so as this went on
uh they actually ended up installing
cameras all around Russell's house which
by the way Jared bought for him
now here's the interesting thing about
these two dudes relationship is that it
seemed to start out as like a friendship
of like two mutual like you know they
they were like hey you're a pervert I'm
also a pervert hey let's hang out it was
that kind of thing as it went on though
Jared started getting this weird
power trip over Russell because he had a
lot more money than him and [__] like
that so he would do [__] like he bought
Russell and at this time Russell had
married his wife his name was Angela and
she also had two daughters who I think
when they married were 10 and 13 but
like you know they were married for a
while
we'll get into that in a minute too
but um so he bought the family A house
and he never Jared never tired of
reminding Russell your whole entire life
is due to me like I own your house I pay
your salary I do this and that so you
pretty much have to do whatever I say so
it was like this weird power Dynamic and
another thing that's where you're gonna
love this Jared made
um Russell like if he wanted something
like he made him call him daddy damn why
would I love that I'm just saying that's
what I thought you would think okay all
right all right yeah but it's like the
fact that he's like so like if Russell
asked for something he's like he's like
what can daddy do for you like because
he was the one that had all the money I
thought it was gonna go further than
that I thought he was going to say that
he he uh demand I thought I thought he
was going to demand [__] uh
privileges over his wife
that well that didn't that didn't happen
because his wife was over 18. so yeah so
I guess he wasn't interested so he
wasn't interested well like I said Jared
was
he he was like you know his wives were
appropriate age were his age but a lot
of times like At first like the escorts
that he hired yeah were barely legal
they were just like 18. and what he
would start to do after a while was that
he would hire like an 18 year old escort
on Craigslist and then he would have sex
with her and then he would ask hey do
you know anywhere I can get someone
younger yeah I'll give you a finder's
fee like if you can find me someone
that's younger so that's what he would
do like he would solicit
escorts on Craigslist that were legal
age to bring him younger ones and he
would give them a lot of money if if
they would do that and some of them did
so that was kind of how he found him too
and the thing about it so Russell
installs all these cameras
in his own house
and
um so kids and he would invite kids over
like um his own kids or his uh his kids
friends like his kids friends
um you know kids from the foundation
like they would invite people over and
sometimes Russell would allegedly
um kind of apply them with alcohol and
things like that to make them a little
more pliable
and then he would they would um you know
have all these secret cameras in there
and they would be like dressing and
showering and things like that and they
would keep all of the [__] footage
now if the footage was really good uh
Russell would send it to Daddy right
being Jared
um hey check this out if it wasn't that
great he would just keep it for his own
self but they did do a lot of um
Kitty prawns in the house you know what
I mean so so there's that
now
like I said there's so there's this
whole thing I don't know there's this
weird [__] power Diana going on uh
with the whole daddy situation that just
like weirded me out also another thing
that Jared would do is that um Russell
had a he was uh was gluten intolerant
so Jared would like force him to eat
food that had gluten in it so he would
like get sick like he would do that to
him too like so
Jared just really sounds like a [__]
monster at this point and like I said I
don't know if he was always like this
and it just this you know losing all the
weight and getting all this money like
at that young age just like unlocked it
or if something triggered it when he was
older I don't really know I mean like I
said I kind of find it hard to believe
that anyone this monstrous was just like
that it just popped out I think that it
was probably like happening all during
his childhood but I mean he seemed to
have a normal childhood like he wasn't
abused or nothing now Russell uh on the
other hand Russell Taylor
um at least according to him was
horribly abused as a child like sexually
abused um and I think somebody mentioned
in the comments earlier that like some
of his mother's friends like his mom
used to kick the [__] out of him he was
also sexually abused by an older
neighbor boy who also shot him in the
back I think with a pellet gun or
something like that
um for you know threatening to tell on
him so there was that and then like I
think he went lived with his dad and
like some of his dad's friends like
abuse him too and like I said that
doesn't excuse anything because a lot of
people have been through horrible
childhoods like that and didn't grow up
to be abusers themselves but I'm just
saying that that's and I don't actually
know if it's true but that was the story
that he told anyway
so so here's the thing
so that kind of [__] is all uh going on
and there's also kind of like
um
a thing where
so it here's the thing so
Rochelle the woman that
um Jared was having like kind of an
ongoing off-again on-again relationship
like every time he went down to Florida
essentially they would hook back up
Rochelle started getting
um suspicious of him
right around 2007-2008.
because of an offhand comment he made
when they were at some you know function
at a middle school and Jared made some
kind of comment about how he found
Middle School girls hot
and Rochelle thought this was kind of
gross
and so she started
the thing about Rochelle is she's kind
of a I don't know if I'd say like a
controversial figure because there's
some people that said oh well she knew
what he was doing this whole time and
she didn't do anything about it but the
thing about it was that there are
records of her reporting his weird ass
behavior and like weird-ass [__] that he
said and like weird ass [__] that he
texted to her and stuff like that as far
back as 2007 like she reported him to
the Sarasota police and it seemed like
no one really did anything about it
because they said well just saying [__]
like that is not really illegal which
yeah that's technically true but you
would think that with all of the [__]
she amassed so the thing about it was
that Rochelle
she decided what she was going to do
because Jared kept saying this [__] up
[__] and he actually admitted to her
that he had gone to Thailand
and had sex with a girl who was nine
[Music]
um
then she decided she was gonna start
saving everything and she was going to
start like recording everything he said
and like keeping all his text messages
and all that [__] and she did it for
like years and years and she apparently
kept trying to inform the authorities
about it like I said she went to the
Sarasota police at first and they didn't
listen she went to the FBI and you know
the FBI kind of were like yeah okay but
we don't have there's like there's no
solid evidence all you have is
recordings of him saying this [__] which
is not illegal technically they didn't
have enough solid evidence like I said
it's not like they went in his house and
file I mean it's not like they went in
his house and found Kitty prawns in his
house
um they did later but I mean they didn't
at that time so they didn't have enough
evidence to even get a search warrant so
they didn't do that so for like seven
years she's kind of like I said it
wasn't constant she didn't live with him
or nothing but she um every time that he
came to Florida they would hook up and
she would like record everything that he
said and he keep everything that he
wrote to her and like everything so that
she could and she kept trying to like
tell law enforcement about him but
apparently they didn't do anything about
him for like a really long time which is
pretty [__] up you know what I mean
um so yeah so so there's that whole
situation
now
so how he ended up
um
well the thing about it okay I want to
go back to Rochelle again for a second
because I forgot to mention this
because what ended up happening was that
not only did he admit that he had gone
around the world and had sex with
nine-year-olds and [__] like that
um and he didn't care if they were boys
or girls or whatever it's like just
younger they were the better they were
pretty much and he said he would go to
other countries and he would like pay a
mom to like pimp out their kid [__] like
that and he would tell her all of this
[__] with her just blatantly he just
said it like it was normal like over the
phone and she said she was so [__]
grossed out by this because she had kids
of her own right and so she was like the
fact that I just don't listen this
[__] like saying all this was
really like taking a toll on her because
she does did this for years and years
and the thing about it too was that he
eventually because she kind of played
along because she was trying to get all
this evidence like hoping that they
would arrest him
so she played along and like acted like
I don't know if she acted like she was
into the same [__] but she just like
didn't judge him for it you know what I
mean she was just like oh that's
interesting or whatever
so then he starts saying stuff like hey
would you set up a camera in your house
so I can watch your kids
he said that to her [__] face damn
like can you imagine the [__] balls
it would take yeah to like say to like a
woman that you're sleeping with that has
kids hey would you mind setting up some
cameras so I can watch your kids get
naked what the [__] man can you imagine
saying that to another human he's
[__] crazy he's yeah like I said what
the [__] is wrong with this dude you
crazy I mean that's [__] insane
so yeah so she like I said she keeps
going to law enforcement relationship
like I said eventually she went to the
FBI and they were like well look we
can't just saying something like that
it's not illegal it's like not enough
yeah you can't you can't just say oh
middle schoolers you're hot it's like
that's not illegal like I just said it's
just there like I didn't mean it
obviously there's um something else kind
of coming to mind now you're talking
about talking about law enforcements in
action on it
kind of brings me back to this one
contract that we were on one of the
staff members she was a ex
parole officer
and we were in the lunchroom
and uh in between [__] classes and
she uh somebody's brought up all these
damn petos and [__]
and she said yeah that's all [__]
they need to [__] um back off on all
that
crap you should see the the problem it's
doing and for the entire prison and
parole system and like what are you
talking about she said most of the [__]
is these 12 to
17 year old girls
send in nude selfies and [__]
to guys that they like who are in their
late teens early 20s and then those
those guys are doing [__] time and
rune for life
and uh she was like
because those girls know what they're
doing this woman said that those girls
know what they're doing sending them
photographs they want to send them
because why are you throwing these kids
in jail for that and that [__]
ex-c cops and contractors didn't like
that
I was just like
well how many of them are there and she
goes oh the whole system's just [__]
flooded with them and in some states
they can't even [__] live it they put
them all these sex offenders
restrictions on them they can't even
live anywhere where so they end up in
these homeless shelters
just something to consider
well that's the thing it's just like
everything else is all about contacts
yeah obviously you know this is a 20
something 30 something year old man
talking about having sex with a
nine-year-old girl yeah
that's [__] yeah oh that's miles away
yeah from you know a 16 year old with a
13 year old girlfriend that's weird but
it's like not I don't see that that's
obviously not the same thing she was she
was saying most of the pedo offenders in
the system are not this
most of them are these dudes in their
late teens early 20s who end up photos
that's why everything has to be
everything everything has to be taken on
a case-by-case basis something like this
obviously this is blatant yeah I mean
this is [__] up like I said he was
going around the world paying
for as young as he could get him you
know what I mean yeah
um and that is obviously [__]
predatory and asking women he was like
normal age women that he was sleeping
with hey can I put secret cameras in
your kids bathroom he's crazy
I mean who the [__] it he's lost he's
lost touch with reality if some if I was
talking to somebody and like he just
said that I was like did you just say
that out loud
losing all that weight [__] drove him
crazy
what the [__] man like who's
in what universe is that okay to say out
loud maybe it's the kind of situation
where he's a sheltered guy who didn't
develop very much I kind of think that
was and I'm not excusing it I'm just
saying that he just like yeah so he's
kind of real retro and he's [__]
stunted growth from being a kind of a
sheltered fat boy and then all of a
sudden he's a [__] Superstar skinny
[__] Superstar [__] yeah
he's got all this money he could go
everywhere he can do whatever he wants
whatever he wants and then just and he
doesn't can't handle it
clearly he's lost his [__] a clear
view of what's real and what isn't he
thinks he can just do anything now
[__] needed a beat down and he
just need to beat down that's all it is
he just he didn't get enough beats I
feel like he just had the one like in
prison which we'll get into in a little
bit but somebody said that about my kids
I don't have the kids but I'll just
[__] get ready
[__] blows yeah I don't think you
would even finish that sentence
no to be honest nope
yeah be a whirlwind you wouldn't even
finish what you were saying
your face would be caved in
he'd wake up like and rightfully wake up
a few days later what happened he's in
the hospital
yeah what's happened you brain [__]
mouth that's what happened yeah why are
my ears ringing
I mean Jesus Christ
so
so yeah
first all right so um
so yeah so so as I said poor Rochelle I
know that some I have seen some
documentaries that kind of blamed her
like she oh she knew what he was doing
this whole time and she didn't do
anything about it but from everything
that I've seen and like I said I wasn't
there yeah listen to what it meant to 88
said that's what she said a lot of that
[__] that yeah that that ex-parole
officer said there was a lot of that
[__]
that guys were getting caught up over
stupid [__] go ahead and read it
yeah it said it happens guy in gal both
16 and a relationship exchanged uh
sexting messages images were still on
this phone four years later and he was
charged with having uh Kitty prawns yeah
yeah he's like what the [__] the cops
thinking there wasn't Kitty prawns
during the time he was getting it it
just it just aged into that yeah
yeah but you know what are you gonna do
like I said you can't
I got or I used to have photographs of
Brazilian girls I grew up with in Tonga
at the [__] at the [__] pool
in Brazil where I grew up in and that
would probably be considered Kitty
prawns by by today's standards because
they were just wearing what was called
fio Dental which means dental floss the
only thing that was covered was just
like nipples and [__] just not even
barely the front patch
and the [__] string bikinis on there
were just like dental floss
you know but
that was Brazil man in the [__] 80s
everybody wore them that was culturally
acceptable
yeah so
um so yeah so Rochelle spent seven years
uh
friend friends with this dude trying to
get enough evidence for somebody to like
pay attention now there were some other
rumors too there was this woman named
Cindy Mills who was actually a Subway
franchise owner
and her and Jared had also been [__]
for a while and she was also suspicious
because of all this weird [__] because
like I said he was he just ran his
[__] mouth it was like he didn't even
think it was weird
like so like women he was sleeping with
he's like oh yeah like nine-year-olds
they're totally like Foxy what do you
know what I mean he would say weird [__]
like that and so like a lot of them uh
understandably were a little alarmed by
this so Cindy Mills actually went to
um that he's talking about it to people
thinking that they wouldn't be alarmed
see that's what I mean he's crazy it's
just like the fact I mean at least well
I'm not gonna say that but it's like you
know usually people that are into this
kind of [__]
um at least have enough sense to like
not blab about it to just all in Sundry
Jared did not seem to have that I mean
he just was openly I mean he wasn't on
TV like he didn't go on like [__]
Maury Povich or anything like being like
yeah I did kids you know what he wasn't
doing that but it's like he really
didn't seem to have any qualms about
telling women that he was sleeping with
or you know or friends of his that he
hadn't known for very long that he was
into that
and like acting like it was not a big
deal maybe
I just kind of feel like he was acting
like it wasn't and I'm just like the
fact that he didn't think that other
people be like the [__] you talking
about bro like just shows how [__]
out of it he was yeah Christ
so yeah so Rochelle is doing this for
seven years like I said she's trying to
get all this evidence but it seems like
no matter how much evidence she gets
which like I said is usually text
messages
um you know recordings like phone
recordings things like that of him just
saying really [__] up [__] I mean he's
saying some really [__] up [__] like
about all the [__] that he has done and
the [__] that he wants to do and all
this other kind of stuff and she keeps
taking it to the authorities and they're
just like well you know that's not
illegal just he's just talking so they
can't really do anything we need like
more solid evidence so how did this
[__] end up getting caught you
want to know which it was kind of
convoluted but this is kind of like an
interesting this is kind of interesting
how to do with Russell Taylor actually
so what ends up happening
is then a 2014
uh the uh authorities opened up an
investigation into Russell Taylor
um now a woman who is only known as Jane
Doe
um filed a complaint
and uh basically this woman said that
Russell Taylor had offered to send her
um images of children and also of
animals
um now this woman had been friends with
Russell and his wife whose name was
Angela for a long time like I guess her
and her husband had been friends with
them like you know a couple friends and
then like her husband had died and so
she maintained the friendship now
Russell and Angela it should be noted
were swingers uh so they were often
sharing uh off with uh other couples and
whatnot so they were into all that kind
of stuff
so um this woman Jane Doe said at first
like Russell started sending her like
sexually explicit text messages which
she wasn't alarmed about at first
because she knew that Russell and Angela
were swingers and had like an open
marriage and so she was just like oh
whatever that's Russell being Russell
like she didn't really think anything
that weird about it but then
um it seemed like the messages started
getting like more and more like they're
pushing more boundaries kind of like
um basically
one of the messages that he sent was
because this Jane Doe woman had a farm
and he was like um well how much do you
mind if me and Angela come out there and
essentially like have sex with one of
your horses yeah okay so they asked that
and the woman's like uh you know kind of
like that and then Russell sent
um Jane Doe a picture of his wife Angela
getting
um
getting head from a dog okay okay all
right yeah so they're into the Beast
seat yeah all right they're yeah they're
into um bestiality Feast
I'm trying to like I'm trying to think
of funny ways like not to say the words
that's why I keep saying Kitty frogs
yeah instead of like I know it's
probably gonna like it it's monetized
anyway but it's like it's it's amusing
me to like come up with different things
so yeah so she sends this picture and
it's like hey this is Angie with her
ex's dog or something like that
so uh you know that's great so then
after this it's like hey can we come
have sex with your horses which I'm not
really sure how you would answer that
question it's just like I'd rather you
did it you know what I mean I don't know
so then Russell sends her another
message and is like something like oh
well do you want to see some pictures of
like some young girls and Jane Doe is
like well well how young are we talking
about and Russell's like well how how
young are you comfortable with kind of
thing like he asked and she's like um
legal age I would rather and he seemed
like kind of bummed out like by that
answer
and uh so yeah so and the thing about it
was that Jane Doe when she made this
report to the police she's like I think
it's like you know you not only just
want to have sex with horses but he's
also like saying that he's gonna send me
messages of you know underage girls and
like he's also hinted that he's gone
overseas and had sex with underage girls
and [__] like that
um now the only picture that she got
from him was the dog picture
which you know good boy Gator
Tom knows what I'm talking about the
video we came across something we came
across a video a long time ago when we
went down some around all over the
rabbit holes
and I was just a girl climbed into the
kettle
yeah I don't know where the [__] did we
find that video there was a [__]
cotton comment underneath there that was
very credible he goes he goes I know who
this is this is my ex-girlfriend [__]
she did this video this video in this
video she's hilarious and the guy gave
the [__] links and it did lead to
other videos of that girl and she would
just do things for [__]
like I don't dare just sucking you know
yeah her face wasn't covered up and she
was because a lot of times people she
better have money too that are into
squeastiality yeah yeah
um a lot of them will wear masks and
stuff like that no not her no she was a
rich girl too
well I guess she was like well I have
she was just like yeah she should just
get away with it well I guess if you
have a lot of money jumped into dog
kennel with [__] Gator and Gator
[__] put it to her
yeah that was the dog's name what kind
of dog was it I don't remember it was a
I don't even remember how he was a
pitbull that's right I don't even
remember how he came across the Pitbull
oh my God but now it's like every time
but now every time we hear anything
about it
um bestiality we're always just like
good boy Gator she jumps up because good
boy
it was so [__] weird damn if we come
across the camera up and everything for
this come across some weird [__] on the
internet sometimes the internet's kind
of a scary place now they're
um
this whole thing about going to the
stable and [__] messing with male
horses and [__] you had you know I I'm
from from that background in the horse
industry that's easier said than done
that's some kind of a [__] pedestrian
civilian fantasy
because most of the male horses are
geldings and they're not going to be
interested you can't do anything with
those guys they don't really have any
kind of sex drive
so that means you need a breeding stud
and those dudes are dangerous all right
you can't have them you couldn't try to
arrange something like that and have
that go down real well I can't
understand how you could control
something like that on camera
if you've ever seen what horse breeding
entails
a woman doesn't weigh very much man
[__] one wrong move and [__] that
woman well what that woman could just be
kicked or crushed yeah because uh
the stud [__] he [__] he's into it
man and he's [__] gets frustrated you
know and you'd have to trick him into it
you'd have to put a mare in front of him
and then you send a woman in there
and I don't think he tolerated
oh now there are some videos of certain
[__] going on but I can tell that it's
kind of faked you know what I mean
a true brood a true breeding stud would
be dangerous
very dangerous
and they're dangerous to a female horse
to a mayor
so I don't believe what they're saying
Senor well I don't know if they'd ever
actually done it with a horse but it's
like I guess they were like intrigued by
the idea so they wanted to know yeah if
they could I don't know if he wanted to
[__] a horse or if he wanted the horse
to [__] his wife or I don't really know
what I don't know what the specifics
were I didn't really look into it
because you know it's kind of gross
um senior stick said the story is
getting more and more depressing yeah
yeah uh Mr 88 said when he was busted
this is Jared he said he'd been
insulated and had no consequences his
entire life yeah I kind of got that
um he was told the rules did not apply
to him while not an excuse he is right
yeah and this went wrong in the most
horrible of ways I mean seriously so I
guess this is a kid who I mean he said
he started getting fat when he was like
eight or nine years old and so for his
whole teenage years his whole college
Years and stuff like that he was
morbidly obese and so he didn't he
couldn't have like a normal life he
didn't have any girlfriends he didn't
really go out and do anything he mostly
ignored yeah he just basically sat on
his room and played video games like all
of those years and then suddenly you
know he's thin he's famous he's Rich
yeah and he just seems to do anything I
mean he did for a long time I mean you
know it seems like
he wasn't even hiding it really like
particularly and like a lot of people
reported him but nobody really did much
of anything about it until like much
later on so like I said so this is
Russell
so this woman
um is like look he sent me all of this
stuff about you know [__] a horse and
[__] Miners and things like that and
it's like and look he sent me all these
links so the authorities look at all the
links that he had that Russell had sent
this woman
and a lot of them were
um you know squeastiality videos and
some other ones that were you know that
were very uh
uh minor oriented let's call it that
um but yeah there were some stuff like
dogs horses all that kind of stuff
and um so basically what ended up
happening with that was that and this
seems weird to me because it seems like
to me Rochelle who had been sleeping
with Jared and was recording all the
[__] about him
um the fact that she had seven years of
texts and recordings and stuff like that
of Jared basically saying yeah I totally
went to Thailand and you know had sex
with a nine-year-old blah blah and like
the fact that she had like tons of like
stuff of him saying that wasn't enough
to like get an investigation but the
fact but then when like animals got
involved like with Russell then suddenly
like the authorities were interested I
know Isla wasn't the same authorities
necessarily so maybe it was like a
different thing but it just seemed like
I don't know it just seemed like this
one woman came forward and said look at
this [__] up [__] that this dude sent
me and the authorities like yeah we need
to get into that
so um the thing about it too though is
that some of the videos that he sent
they knew that that they had been shot
you know the ones of kitty prawns that
had been shot in his house you know what
I mean so it's like oh well he's
producing it yeah which you know so that
was enough to like get a search warrant
for Russell Taylor's house Ben is saying
read what Ben said where is it right
there there was a Roman Empress who came
to a bad end after she constructed some
sort of rig to allow her to have sex
with horses yeah false false that that
that what you're what you're repeating
is a rumor that was told about Catherine
the Great
all right that was a rumor about her it
was it was some anti-russian propaganda
I guess
but no they said that about Catherine
the Great but it's not true that's where
you're getting that whoever told you
that
Mr 88 said wasn't there a male porn star
that was killed by being [__] by a
horse I don't know Tom and Jen haven't
said haven't said and everything I know
about porn I learned from them yeah not
sure for real I have heard that but I
don't know if that's true or not and I
don't remember what his name was I have
heard that story how long have you been
streaming two hours okay [__] man is it
time for commercials
um probably I've still got [__] to do
but yeah we still got [__] to do but
this is about the half wave Mark
probably there's gonna be a four hour
show people it better not be because
it's already 9 30 and I have to go to
bed soon you know I mean I gotta get up
early all right uh all right but we're
gonna do like a little bit of
commercials and then we'll come back and
finish up the stuff with the with the
kitty prawns and the bestiality so yeah
we'll be right back in just a minute
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
expired
and darkness
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right we're back we had to talk
about porn
[Laughter]
like always Bill's impressed with the
[__] that we've done so far he's like
he's like you guys are gonna be great
yeah when you send me when you got the
intros cut and they should be five
second intros they should be very yeah I
know okay I I've made two five second
intros just for the video good good but
like I said I wanted to show you both of
them and I might do another version too
I'm gonna throw them by a bill too
because he says he may need some [__]
like that okay all right we should get
some other customers
but yeah so that's what we'll do but
well because we were saying because we
were saying like while the commercials
were playing I was like why can't people
just send like normal porn like back and
forth instead of like why do you gotta
get like children and animals involved
they want there's plenty of like
consenting adults that will do
absolutely whatever you want you look
hard enough you can find anybody
whatever your Kink is whatever your
fetish is there's somebody out there
that will do that for you especially if
you have money yeah and it's like even
if you have to pay them but it's like
that's the thing it's like just do that
like don't involve like non-consenting
animals Miners and animals that should
just leave them alone Jesus Christ why
is that hard I don't know I don't have
to say Gator Gator [__] consented
he's one that [__] jumped on her
maybe she put peanut butter or something
no Gator knew what Gator knew what that
was he's like okay yeah yeah okay she
hangs like she hangs like sausages I'm
male too I'm male two I make eye contact
with the dog through the video going
like yeah you know what you're doing you
know what you're doing he's like this is
unbelievable
I can't believe this [__] it's like some
cross species like I feel like I'm doing
it's a wow [__] man I can't believe it I
wonder if like if dogs had thumbs he
could have filmed that for like whatever
the dog version of like PornHub is yeah
yeah dog PornHub
foreign
but yeah I'm just saying that I kind of
feel like by their nature like animals
probably can't consent but yeah I mean
he he did seem enthusiastic I am going
to say that much but you know what I
mean yeah I wouldn't recommend like
looking it up but it's we just came
across it accidentally I don't even
remember Victor Victor Garcia
if your boys having sex with some chick
he looks at you he makes eye contact
with you is that gay yes I'm just asking
go ahead Jeff everything's gay yeah all
right
and that's all right
but I'd be like don't look at me man
yeah y'all are weird
kill these weird little rules and stuff
about what's gay and what's not don't
worry about it
don't worry too much eye contact man
it's fine too much eye contact it's fine
don't worry about it
everything's just like a big beautiful
Spectrum don't worry about putting
everything in [__] boxes man uh so
yeah so here's the thing no I'm just
saying
so here's the thing
so Russell
um because he had sent all of these uh
questionable links to this woman what
Victor says it's not gay unless your
balls touch yeah yeah I've heard that
that's the role I've heard that's the
rule that's funny yeah your balls are
touching yeah oh [__] dude you got me
you had to put it we're gay now
just do this doing them now we have to
get gay married dude's doing the [__]
Devil's threesome and [__] and they got
a [__] like a piece of brass glass
plate in between them so they're balls
don't touch that'd be hilarious will you
still laugh it'd be hilarious we used to
laugh at um like I just I used to see
this a lot me and my friend uh you know
me and my friend Jen would get her name
was also done and we would go to the
movies all the time
two dudes who were friends would go to
the movies together and they always sat
with a seat in between them because it
would be gay if they were you yeah and
it's like we used to think that was so
funny I'm like look it's it's the no
homo seat yeah yeah I don't understand
I'm like imagine being so insecure that
you have to leave a whole seat in
between yourself so that's not what it
is
that's everybody know we're not a couple
but no one's looking at you like that
it's like just sit next to your friend
like a normal [__] person in fact it
it actually like brings more attention
to it when you leave a seat in between
because everyone's like that's something
why are you doing that only in the mind
of a woman
and then women are thinking well they
must be gay because they're really
worried about everyone thinking that
they're not yeah because so they're over
compensating no you know what I mean no
that's that's what that's what that's
what I would think that's just what
women think that's what I would think
and who cares about women yeah that's
just a women thing who cares about women
nobody cares what we think women are
trying to make [__] gay
they got a gay fantasy
yeah Victor says forget to say no homo
gay shake your socks off gay
yeah it's the official no homo see
that's what we used to call it
I was like look I was like oh my God
that's so funny I was like they're
trying so hard to like [__] it's just
like maybe so it's okay if they put
their arms around each other like one
dude puts why would I care I don't know
them stretch it out like that I think
you all think that that other people
care what y'all are doing nobody cares
nobody cares I don't care I don't know
y'all so I'm just saying do what you
want I don't give a [__] but if they put
a seating between them then they're gay
no I'm just saying I thought it was
funny because it just seemed like they
were trying too hard okay like for
people than not notice it but I'm like
well now they're making me notice it
because they're leaving a very obvious
even though I wouldn't even think either
way either I really would have known I
wouldn't notice you I was like just sit
next to your friend like a normal
[__] person why do you gotta like be
weird about it I don't know it's just
weird to me so uh so yeah so so that's
what we were saying like before I was
just like I don't know why people can't
just exchange normal porn like with
adults like normal people but okay
why you gotta be like yeah he's saying
I'm laughingly insecure no I'm not
that's [__] funny no he said no Tom
it is laughably insecure it is yeah it
is okay it is laughably insecure I
wouldn't have thought of it
but
seeing it I would understand it I was
like okay it is very yeah yeah it seems
very insecure like I said just sit next
to your buddy No One's Gonna think that
you're gay it's fine that's your friend
you sit next to your friend that's
normal no one would think anything about
that but like I said the fact that you
feel the need to leave leave a seat that
it's like well that tells me that you're
thinking too much about it which is like
really try hard and I'm just like what
if you've got a guy in a back your bike
I would literally I would probably not
even notice that
I don't think it's gay I would probably
not know because second Brazilian
[__] no one would think that because
I was just kind of like just trying to
get the dude they're just trying to get
something good to do there yeah like I
said I think that people like doing that
or like they're more worried about it
than anyone else in the world is I don't
know everyone else would be just like
hey they're giving somebody a ride
somewhere Brazilian police like a normal
person Brazilian police Commandos they'd
have a dude [__] ride in a [__]
Enduro it's a cop and then have another
dude on the back [__] turned around
backwards with a submachine gun and they
would ride like that that was I thought
that [__] was [__] Macho as [__]
see Victor says my old high school best
friend was the type to leave a seat
between us at the movies then blow me
when we got high at his house oh oh who
said that Victor damn told you damn
Victor told
that's always what that's what I
suspected because like I said you're you
cry because you're trying too hard you'd
consider not a Triumph though right
trying to a Triumph yes
Greg says as long as they're not holding
hands in the middle armrests
like I said so many rules how do you
keep track of all this stuff yeah but
yeah so uh so this [__] is
sending all these weird ass messages to
this woman who was like a friend of his
and his wife's right but he's sending
all this Bulls like hey want to see
pictures of my wife getting cunnilingus
from a dog
no thanks but uh you know thanks for the
offer seriously
um but yeah so he sent it to her anyway
so he's like hey you want to see some
pictures of some really young girls no
thank you but yeah so the fact that he
sent all these weird links and stuff so
she reports them to the authorities
and all of the stuff that was on her
phone was enough for the authorities to
get a search warrant
so they searched his house
um thinking that because some of the
kitty prawns that he had sent to her
like the links
um had clearly been filmed in his house
um they thought well he's probably
producing it in there so we have enough
to get a search warrant so they got a
search warrant and they go in there and
they found all kind of kitty prawns in
there and most of it
a lot of it
um had been was actually Russell
Taylor's uh uh family members but like
cousins nieces nephews [__] like that
um you know uh friends of his kids
that you would invite them over to the
house uh you know give them some alcohol
or something like that and then had all
these secret cameras on them around the
house where he would like film them
you know getting dressed and taking
showers and all this other kind of stuff
so Victor says he misses that dude he
joined the army top
he joined a gay army though I was in a
straight Army
that was the hell yeah
I was in the don't ask don't tell Army
today's Army is just a straight up gay
army now
but I don't know what this okay I was
just like nothing nothing I was just
reading some messages but I wasn't sure
what the context wasn't yeah I don't
know
um so yeah
and then
um after they found all of this uh Kitty
prawns in his house
that had clearly been filmed there and
was friends and family and things like
that and some of friends and family came
forward and said yeah this [__]
like you know filmed us and did all this
[__] without our consent
um so they brought Russell Taylor in for
questioning now Russell Taylor his first
excuse
was that um oh this woman the Jane Doe
who like I said as far as I know has
never been named
the Jane Doe
um she was actually [__] three of the
detectives who were investigating this
case so it should all be thrown out that
was his first story that he was trying
to like get a wriggle out of it with
um and they were like um yeah no that's
not happening but okay
so after they got through that and they
were just kind of like um you're making
that up he's finally like um okay yeah I
did make kitty prawns in my house
but I didn't want to do it
um I actually did it because Jared from
Subway who is my boss yeah asked me to
do it because he wanted which not a lot
of way made we do not alive yeah
it was those five dollar footlongs yeah
um but yeah Victor wishes he could get a
five dollar foot long for five dollars
good
do they even they don't even have that
anymore I don't know I don't know I
haven't been to a Subway in a very long
time I'm [__] with my gay fans
but yeah so uh so yeah so he said no uh
Jared told me to produce the kitty
bronze so that he could see it
so Russell gets arrested
so basically Jared then comes out and is
like I had no idea I'm shocked shocked I
tell you
um I am you know severing all ties yeah
with this Russell Taylor person well
because like I said he wasn't just his
friend but he was also like the head of
the Jared Foundation right I had no idea
that all of this was going on oh my god
dude I'm scandalized at this point
that's funny so you know what I mean I
mean what else is he gonna do right I'm
just saying that that's what are you
gonna do he's like yeah I did that [__]
you know I wish they would at least we'd
know then but you know
um and then behind the scenes though
Jared is like even though in the public
obviously he's like I don't even you
know that that dude that's that's crazy
I don't I'm severing all ties with him
um I didn't know all this was going on
but then behind the scenes he was like
he says to Russell hey keep our [__] on
the DL all uh if you don't then I'm
gonna um take your house away where your
wife and kids still live because like I
said he owned it so so he didn't give
him the house he just bought a house and
let him he bought a house and let him
live in it yeah so he could hold it so
he could hold it over him yeah that's
why so well so he could have like
control over his life like I said
um but he's like I'll you know if you
keep your mouth shut about me like don't
you know blab about what we were doing
then I will make sure that your wife and
kids are taken care of while you're in
prison and you know I'll even put some
money in your little jail account thing
and you can like buy cigarettes or
whatever or so I was watching The Casual
criminalist with Simon Whistler earlier
because he did like an hour episode
about this dude and he's like well don't
they give you money in prison like to
buy noodles and [__] and I was like
noodles and [__] yeah for some reason I
thought that was a robin yes yeah that's
what I thought noodles and [__] I was
like that's I think the ramen Vienna
sausages I like Ramen
[__] certain candy bars
they get ice cream
because they get in there okay sounds
kind of nice yeah
but yeah so um
so yeah so he had all the [__] to hold
over him he's like well I'll just you
know as long as you keep your trap shut
about what you were doing
then I'll make sure that you know your
house is paid for and your family is
taken care of because like I said he did
have a wife and the wife had two
daughters also
which I've heard that Russell and the
wife were
um trying to pimp out
what the daughters Russell's daughters
well they weren't Russell's daughters
they were Russell's wife daughters like
from her previous nine and twelve I
think they were 10 and 13. like when
they first got married and then later on
they were like giving them alcohol and
drugs and [__] like that and they were
like hey let's invite some friends over
it it was that kind of situation yeah
yeah allegedly I'm just you know I'm
allegedly
so uh so yeah
now
so after a while like I said
um finally because Russell Taylor uh was
getting into trouble and because he had
said hey I was filming all this Kitty
prawns for my boss Jared Fogle
um
they actually ended up taking uh Russell
Taylor's phone like confiscating it
and they found out like on his phone
it turned out that he had sent a video
of a minor
um to Jared
and Jared had replied to this with a
bunch of texts saying something to the
effect of thank you for giving daddy his
fix of kitty prawns
so
um they also found out that a bunch of
the kids that were in because like I
said when they raided Russell Taylor's
house they found like thumb drives they
found a laptop they found like all kind
of stuff that had all of this um you
know CP Kitty bronze on it and it's all
he produced it not all of it but most of
it most of it um some of it and some of
the ones that they found like some of it
that um Jared had he had bought it like
on the dark web yeah but a lot of it had
been produced at Russell Taylor's house
from all the secret cameras and [__]
like that that he set up because like I
said they were inviting kids over and
essentially like getting them drunk and
you know doing [__] to them right and
the the thing about it too was that
Russell and his wife were in some of the
videos doing some [__] so they ended up
spoiler alert getting a lot of prison
time Russell Taylor got 27 years
and his wife Angela got 33 years because
she was in some of the videos she got
more she did yeah she got more because
she was supposed to know better
yeah I'm not really sure why she got
more maybe they could prove that she was
doing things because I think she was on
video more than he was that was the only
thing I could think of because I thought
that was weird too because normally that
wouldn't happen but
um
yeah I think it was because she appeared
in some of the videos like actually
doing the [__] so they actually had
evidence well there she is right there
doing whatever so
so they gave her more you know but um
but yeah so because
um he could prove it was from his phone
that he was actually sending Kitty
prawns to Jared and Jared was like into
it and they also found out too that a
lot of the kids that were in the videos
were
um kids that Jared knew like from the
non-profit you know like and he what he
would do they found out later was
sometimes when he would go to a middle
school like to give a talk he would take
pictures of kids that he thought were
attractive and would send them to
Russell and be like hey set that up you
know what I mean so it was that
calculated wow so that's what I'm saying
it's like this dude is like a [__]
monster
so it's like I talked him into it
hey Russell no the the kids
paid them I'm not sure if they paid or
or like I said if they just brought him
to the house because they said hey Jared
and he's a celebrity and then they
drugged him I don't know what the [__]
got him drunk and then got High I mean
they did like get some of them drunk for
sure but um yeah I don't think any of
them really went willingly like I said
they're hard to do well I think that
they were invited to it's like oh it's
like we're having this Jared Foundation
uh you know special thing like all these
the best kids are gonna come to the
house we're gonna have a big party or
something like that and Jared was famous
and a lot of these kids were real young
and they kind of like looked up to him
yeah so
um they wouldn't have thought anything
of it I guess and yeah leap into sex
though see I don't I don't make the
mental leap I would think that'd be hard
unless it's unless the reality is a lot
darker than that maybe it's easy to do
I would not like to think that but
the thing is I think that they got the
kids there under false pretenses is what
they did I didn't matter once they're
there under false pretenses then you
flip it around then those kids know what
the hell the hell what the hell is
actually well that's why I think when
they got there I think they were I mean
I don't know I'm just making a leap here
but I'm thinking that they would like
essentially get them dry or like roofie
them like I'm thinking
hmm you know I would hate to think that
it's easy
see I don't think it would be because
either 99 of parents out there and would
be like
well 99 of parents out there hey you
want to go to some stranger's house for
some no no most parents would say no
you know I I feel like
I mean where your kids are concerned
people are very protective maybe they're
just around adults they're kind of
intimidated to just go along with
Ben says offer kids free stuff and
they'll be there yeah maybe
I mean these kids were pretty young
though so I think they're like their
parents had to be involved
I don't know I hate to blame the parents
because the thing about it was that
Jared and I think he was very aware of
this too he was a celebrity and he kind
of had the Persona of being it's like
this every man nice guy everybody kind
of perceived him that way now it's like
people that knew him were like no he's
like a raging dick hole but nobody else
knew that like the public didn't know
that you know what I mean so
right and it's like so everyone thought
he was like super trustworthy well he's
a celebrity he's famous like he's on the
TV he seems like the next guy yeah right
but it's just kind of like now see I was
again I was like I was listening to
casual criminalist and he's like well
didn't they vet him didn't Zeb didn't
Subway vet him before they hired him but
I was like well before they hired him he
hadn't done anything not that I know of
I don't think he did all this [__] until
after I'm not saying that he didn't
think about it he probably did because I
don't think that this just came out of
nowhere but I don't think he really had
the means or yeah Camp guy brings up
Michael Jackson situation yeah there's a
good um Channel called razor fist all
right
and this guy he does a bunch of heavy
metal reviews he does politics and
everything he's he kind of I like him
he's kind of an entertaining show host
he did a whole video on Michael Jackson
he's a Michael Jackson fan
he thought Michael Jackson was guilty
but then the more he looked into the
accusers and everything's going he
thought Michael Jackson was set up he
did a whole
oh I think it was a two-hour video where
he lays out a pretty good defense of
Michael Jackson
that Michael Jackson probably didn't do
that that he was set up
um I mean I don't know I don't know we
should probably do a show about Michael
Jackson one of these days I might I know
a couple of guys I thought the dude was
guilty but after watching that razor
fist video he gives a [__]
real good defense of him
um that there's a lot of [__] about the
accusers that doesn't add up
um so
now was Michael Jackson into that [__] I
think he was
I think he was
but I don't think he was doing it
he had a Peter Pan complex I think he
liked little white boys
but I don't think he was having sex with
him
Ben says when the police raided Michael
Jackson's house they didn't find
anything yeah I don't think he was
having sex with him
um what was his name Corey Feldman yeah
who uh spoke out a lot against abuses
happening in Hollywood against little
boys said that Michael Jackson was
[__] spotless he said Michael Jackson
never [__] did anything he was great
that he never did anything
and I think Corey film also was he was
calling out a bunch of other ones but he
said Michael Jackson wasn't guilty
so
he may have got a bum wrap
I thought he was guilty I mean I'd like
I said I don't really know enough to
make a judgment either way
um I don't really have I'm really kind
of on the fence about that I don't
really like I said watch the razor of
this video he did all the investigations
about it all out and he said if I looked
into it I would well like I said some of
the [__] that he did was like kind of
questionable but I don't really know if
that was just because of how weird he
was he was weird and ripe for extortion
that's this is what razor fist says he
was weird and he was ripe for extortion
and he probably was into that
but he thinks he wasn't actively doing
it he he thinks he was asexual kinda
uh you remember he always did come
across he was like that
um and that he that he had he didn't do
anything with those little boys he was
just that he was that weird he was so
weird that he wouldn't do anything with
him because he would think that a dude
would make his house we'll see that's
what I mean because like I know this is
[__] up to say but like a normal
person would think a normal person
wouldn't do that but a normal person
would think that would think that
something's going on that something was
going on I mean because most of the time
it is yeah the Neverland Ranch was a
[__] amusement park all right if you
had some dude in your neighborhood set
up a damn toy train and had an amusement
park going 24 7 some old [__] 60 year
old white dude and [__] he doesn't have
any children he just sits out there
trying to call the children yeah you'd
be all over you'd be like this
motherfucker's got to go okay I wouldn't
even let Pookie go to that right she's a
cat right
I think what it was Michael Jackson
wanted to be a little white boy that's
what I think it was I don't think he
wanted to have sex with him he wanted to
be a little white boy
and I think Corey basically said the
same thing
yeah but they tried to extort him for
money
which uh if that's real if that's the
real if that's really what happened then
I got
then my respected Michael Jackson would
be restored
you know what I mean he had a mental
problem
I don't think he was abusing those boys
um he was a good artist he could write
some [__] good pop music for his time
he wouldn't have lasted though Prince
was better
well I agree with that
Mr 88 said uh we see this with Bill
Cosby OJ and hundreds more celebrities
get pre-deefined yeah because I kind of
feel like
there's a thing where I mean celebrities
you feel like you know them right
because you see them all the time even
though you don't know them personally
but it's just kind of like a product of
our uh the way our brains evolved
people that you see all the time and you
hear them talking all the time that must
be somebody like in your family or
somebody in your extended friend group
or your village or something like that
so it's like you see a celebrity that
you see on TV all the time as an
extension of your
tribal group yeah and so I kind of feel
like people are willing to extend
um
latitudes to them that they wouldn't
extend to a stranger even though that is
essentially a stranger you don't know
that person
so you know what I mean and I've you
know it's the same thing like you see
somebody
I think that's why everybody was so
shocked when like the [__] about Jared
came out because
he seemed like he was so famous and he
seemed like such a nice person or just
like a regular person and the fact that
he was hiding such
depravity I think really Disturbed
people that somebody that normal
could be doing that [__] but that's the
thing it's like we've talked about this
a lot of times with serial killers and
all these people that are doing this
[__] A lot of them do look kind of
normal
what did you expect her to look like
they don't look like ogres they just
look like [__] regular ass people you
know what I mean yeah regular ass people
most and I'm not trying to like scare
everybody I'm just saying like most
regular ass people are fine it's like
you know 99 of people would never do
[__] like that but it just seems like
people expect them to look
different
and they don't yeah that's all
they just don't they're in there going
on about Neverland Ranch and everything
about how a lot of the stuff that was
claimed in wasn't true yeah
yeah look at look at razor fists [__]
his analysis
there's a good chance Michael Jackson
was set up that he didn't do anything
wrong well like I said that might be an
interesting show yeah we gotta do a show
on it we talked about that a long time
ago yeah it's like like I said I don't
know I don't really have an opinion
either way
um so it might actually be good to do it
because I don't have any kind of biased
run kind of thing like like I said it's
not I'm not a huge fan of his I'm not
you know I like his music I'm not a big
fan so it's just gonna and I didn't
really have a dog in that fight dude was
an enigma
in a way a lot like Elvis Presley just a
weird guy kind of reclusive and very
different personalities but they
probably would have understood each
other
Ben says it wasn't really a mental
problem it was just something Society
frowns on Plenty of old women love
grabbing little kids and pinching them
and cuddling them Etc which I also have
a problem with I really wish people
wouldn't go and grab people without
that's like so that's so weird I used to
Hate That I Used to hate that like it's
like dude I don't know you get the [__]
off me you know what I mean it's like
it's so weird
I like I kind of like that nowadays
they're more like hey you know some old
lady comes up and like starts grabbing
your [__] like you can say hey this
makes me very uncomfortable please don't
[__] touch me you know what I mean
it's like because I didn't like that but
you back then you just kind of had to
like grin and bear it even if you didn't
like it yeah they look like a goddamn
sticksies remember the [__] is yeah and
they're like and that was scary like a
little kid you're a little kid and like
some old bat or some old old dude like
some 90 year old dude you barely knew
who was like your extended or like a
friend of your grandparents or something
like that and they'd come and like
[__] pinch you into it I'm like get
the [__] off me I don't know the [__] I
don't know you gross
Jesus Christ but yeah just like don't
tell your kids they don't don't let old
people touch them like that you know
what I mean that's creepy so yeah
so um so where was I
so uh so they get was from all the [__]
that they got from Russell
um they were actually able to
get uh you know all of the [__] that you
know that they showed that Russell had
sent to Jared and Jared was like woohoo
love that [__] so they were able to get
a search warrant for Jared's house which
they couldn't get before because they
apparently didn't have enough evidence
so said the FBI
so they raid Jared's house this was in
2015 what you got to read what Zach said
where he just did the last three uh I
got just got back from the gay bar was
that what I miss I'm drunk LMAO yes
mortgage well we gotta start over hold
on we gotta start over holy crap we're
like so we've been on for like two hours
a threat then I'm like past my bedtime
but it's it's okay it's okay this is
this is a big story
so um I'm Glad You Came I'm glad you
came though
um so yeah so they raid Jared's house
and in Jared's house well they looked
into his phone
and they found
um a couple images in Jared's phone of
uh Kitty prawns which
um apparently he had forgotten to delete
so you know there's that
um that Taylor had sent to him it's like
hey check this out it was that kind of
situation
also
um they found in Jared's house there was
a laptop that
um Russell had given to him that was
like his special Kitty prawns laptop
that's what that was for so he gave him
that it was it was special
so he gave him that
uh they also found a thumb drive with
just
lots and lots and lots of images and
videos
um of kitty prawns and some of it was
the stuff that Taylor had made at his
house and some of it was stuff that they
discovered that Jared had bought online
um at various Shady
dealers you know what I mean
um some of these videos
were they were um both boys and girls
the youngest person in the videos that
they could determine was six years old
so
remember how we were saying this is
getting more and more depressing yeah
the story's getting more more depressing
six years old
some of this
Kitty prawns that they found
so uh so yeah
so at this point uh 2015 they actually
did have enough evidence finally to
arrest Jared
now
um they also were able to
um investigate the case and they had
enough evidence to back it up that he
had
um
it was child prostitution essentially
what he did because remember how I said
earlier that he would go on Craigslist
and find legal escorts who were 18 and
over supposedly and he would say hey can
you get me some younger ones and so a
couple of times that had happened like
in a few cities I think he did it in New
York City he did it in um Las Vegas he
did it in
um I think St Louis like a couple other
cities where he would go and set up
stuff with like Craigslist escorts who
were over age and say hey can you I'll
give you a finder's fee if you set me up
with someone younger
and so a couple of them did that and so
they had enough evidence of that
um that he had engaged in sex at least
two times with minors and so they were
able to you know and had paid them
or I paid someone to find them for him
so they were able to get enough evidence
of that so they could charge him for
that as well
um so yeah Kansas City Missouri it
wasn't St Louis sorry about that
um so yeah so he gets arrested in 2015.
his second wife uh immediate is like
yeah but I'm out
um she said she didn't know anything
about that and honestly um I kind of
believe her she was like uh yeah I'm
[__] out of here and she just took
the kids and [__] up and honestly she
um also had a restraining order against
him uh she didn't want him to see the
kids which
I you know I don't blame her until
they're 18. and I was just kind of like
well I'm sure when they turn 18 they'll
be like yeah no thanks
no thanks I don't really want to talk to
that dude and like I said I I wouldn't
blame them not not one bit
so basically what ended up happening so
he gets arrested
and hauled in and they tell him what all
the charts were
uh second one second wife leaves him
now he pleads guilty because they gave
him like a plea deal essentially they
said if you plead guilty you can get a
lesser sentence but you have to pay like
this big fine so he ended up paying
um having to pay 1.4 million to all the
victims
um
and they said if he did that like he'd
give I think it ended up being
it's like 150 000 or 200 000 or
something like that like to each of the
victims like in the complaint
so they said if he did that then the
prosecutor wouldn't ask for any more
than 12 years so that's what they ended
up doing but when they went to trial uh
the judge was like I don't think 12
years is enough
so he actually ended up giving or she
actually the the judge was a woman
um she actually ended up giving him 15
and a half years it's federal prison so
you have to serve like I said 88 85 yeah
um so he has to serve 13 years so he
actually won't be out until
2029 I think is the earliest and he
might not be out then that's like just
when he's eligible for parole but that's
not his whole entire sentence
so he's actually like because the judge
well he'll be out if he's got to serve
85 then he gets automatically gets
like a good time 15 good time so 20 29.
unless he does is the earliest so does
something bad and he loses good time
that's how that now I will say that he
he's in a federal prison and he's still
there
um about like only a few months after he
first went to the federal prison one of
the other inmates whose name was Stephen
[__]
um beat the absolute [__] out of him and
probably justifiably so you peed up
yeah because you know how that goes yeah
um but you know and he got like
transferred to another prison and stuff
like that but you know what I mean kinda
I don't know I kind of feel like maybe
they should knock a couple years off
since
doing the world of service but you know
what I mean um so yeah he wasn't like
yeah so so he got to be but other than
that because you do kind of feel like um
you know uh uh crocodiles
uh you know pitos or whatever they don't
do well in prison because the other you
know the other inmates have kids too man
it's like they don't want to think about
this [__] creep yeah you know
scooping on their kids so they're gonna
beat the crap out of you and like I said
I don't condone violence in that
situation but I'm not gonna cry about it
either you know what I'm saying so it's
that kind of situation but he did get
his ass beat but other than that I think
he only got his ass beat like one time
and from everything that I've heard
his time in federal prison has been
kind of cushy as far as prison goes what
I've heard and he says this isn't true
but another inmate who was released
since then and had done some time with
him said yeah he's doing good in prison
like he's taking cooking classes like
he's doing all this stuff like he's
having a [__] high old time
now I don't know if he still has all the
money he did have to pay 1.4 million
to the victims which I'm assuming he
paid he also had to pay 7 million to his
ex-wife like after she divorced him
um but he had a lot more money than that
so I'm assuming he still has money I
don't really know how that works I
understand what Jenny's talking about
you know she's like man he's doing a
good good in prison that kind of [__]
sucks
there's [__] you gotta [__] weigh
against that
yeah he's in prison prison [__] sucks
he can't be in normal society
they're doing stuff with him he's
getting trained in and [__]
Rehabilitation
if you move it to the other end of the
spectrum and make prison hell what you
end up releasing this [__] Carl
panzeram we did a whole [__] yeah
that's that's because I know I'm kind of
like look I know however but and look I
have it too like I have the bloodlust
also it's just kind of like especially
if somebody as shitty as this person
it's like yeah they need to they need
their ass beat yeah so it's like if
somebody beats their ass it's like yeah
I mean like I said I don't condone it
um but if it happens I'm like back in
the place oh well 1800s early 1900s
prison was [__] hell
and to do that doesn't solve anything no
those dudes got out they were [__]
monsters they were even worse
because they just came out of their hard
and cruel as [__] and they're more
Twisted sexuality
go back and look at our show by Carl
panzeram I mean they pick up little boys
take them out on a boat [__] rape
them and then just shoot them pop out
kick them overboard look for the
alligators to get him he'd [__] make
dudes he he'd pull guns on dudes and
make them have sex with each other and
then he'd dive in there and rape someone
then kill him and he was and this is
early 1900s man on a trains he was doing
this to bums
he was a ball he was a [__] psycho
yeah psycho he was a homosexual serial
killer
and a violent one real cruel
and prison kind of made it in prison
well it would start in prison started in
[__] orphanages well yeah
right that's the thing if you treat
someone with cruelty yeah especially
from childhood that's all they know they
don't know how to be any different yeah
so it's like all you're doing is making
a monster and you're just releasing them
on a society so I kind of feel like
I don't know I kind of feel like people
do make fun of the whole like well let's
be nice to them and stuff like that but
I think there is a lot of
um well you can't just be shitty to the
people because that'll just make them
worse yeah they'll retaliate right
that'll just make them worse
pants Ram
and what was weird about pads Ram is he
was just a [__] fear of force of
[__] evil and fury
never committed any crimes against women
that I remembered just men he [__]
hated men
raped and murdered man that's what he
did
he was a demon you know
well serial killers tend to uh torture
and murder those who are there sexually
attracted to you like not across the
board but generally
so I think he got frozen into a
homosexual kind of a thing when he was a
little boy and or an orphanage and they
were the ones that were abusing him and
that's what he got fixated on well he
was just retaliating well like I said
that's why and we talk about this a lot
especially with serial killers because I
know that a lot of serial killers were
abused as children and like I said
that's shitty
um especially if you're a kid but that's
the thing it's one it doesn't excuse
what they did when they were older
because you're old enough to know better
but on the other hand if you raise a
child
um with knowing nothing but violence and
cruelty they don't ever learn anything
different and that's and they're going
to strike back at the world the same way
that the world has treated them yeah and
panzram has a story in the modern
Penitentiary system in the United States
a guard had befriended him and found and
learned listened to his whole story
I don't remember his name but that guy
ended up when he
he got promoted into being a warden and
all kinds of other stuff and ended up
getting into politics and he that guy
ended up revamping the the American
citizen of punishment because of Carl
panzram
said that if you're bad at these dudes
you just [__] cruel to them they
retaliate against Society they get worse
yeah and you you can't release them if
you release them you're releasing a
demon you know
anyway yeah yeah I mean you can't treat
people like [__] their whole entire life
and then expect them to come out into
society be normal yeah that's just not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen
so
that's just how that goes
but uh
but yeah so so basically okay so Jared
pleads guilty which thank God we didn't
have to go through all that kind of [__]
but sticks his ass Matt Bronson yeah I
got the movie somebody sent me the movie
so Sophie sent me the movie one of my
favorites that's a great [__] movie
yeah so good Tom Hardy went my favorite
actor really
yeah I like Tom Hardy I mean he's one of
the best best actors working today for
sure yeah British they got real skills
there when it comes to acting and I'm a
trained actor myself but [__] the
British [__] school of the [__]
Arts their theater schools are [__]
Superior to ours and [__] Bronson
[__] was a great movie kind of like
Clockwork Orange part two we did a
review on it loved that movie
and Tom Hardy man [__] had been a lot
of my favorite movies did a great Bane
did a great Mad Max
I can't understand why he's not James
Bond
he should be too yeah
he'd be a good James Bond I think yeah
and Senor stick said the real guy is
very interesting he is yeah we like we
talked about him a little bit when you
talked about the movie but yeah I mean
you know the movie's great too but
England's most famous convict prisoner
that's what he's talking about yeah his
nickname was Bronson Charles Bronson
yeah well that was his actual name his
name was Charles Bronson was just
actually in charge of profit yeah I
thought it was just nicknames but not
that Charles Bronson you know what I
mean
um mr88 said pants Ram's friend was
Henry lesser the book he wrote about
panzram is one of the two or three best
true crime books ever written okay
because panzram was so forthright yeah
yeah he tell you anything
I'm always kind of interested in I mean
I'm interested in
serial killers I'm interested in what
Insight they have into their own
behavior
some of them seem to have some insight
into their own which is weird to me
because it it feels like if you have
that much Insight in your own behavior
like you wouldn't be doing it
but some of them really do seem very
I don't know if detached is the right
word
compartmentalized
where they can just talk very openly
about what they're like they know that
it's bad they know that it's wrong they
know but they know why they're doing it
and they just do it anyway it's like
that's very that's crazy to me panzram
was about rage and [__] Vengeance and
hatred for mankind that's that's what he
was all about he was honest about yeah
he just hated everybody he hated mankind
yeah well like I said and like I said
not excusing it but his entire life was
pain and suffering and abuse and yeah
you know you treat somebody like that
their whole entire life
you're gonna have a bad time later on
because that dude is gonna
come back at you
that's just what happens you treat
people bad don't be surprised when that
comes back to bite you in the ass prison
should be a cooler you put them in there
and it chills them out they come out and
they come out and come out and dazzle
because that's what it should be
just gotta figure out how to do it yeah
and like I said the best way to do that
I mean we could debate that I do I am a
big advocate of Prisons being they
should teach them [__] they'll you know
they should offer classes they should
like I know a lot of people don't like
oh they should suffer and so I'm like
that's not good for society as a whole I
don't think that's a good idea
right like if but if you're gonna let
those dudes out later on yeah then it
would behoove you to try to make them at
least into productive citizens teach
them a skill yeah um you know give them
anger management something like just a
Penitentiary is a Penitentiary it has a
religious [__] a motive behind it it
comes from the word Penance it's paying
for what you've done
and trying to rebuild the person and to
change them so they can be released into
society it's not it's not hell where
you're
punishing them and trying to torture
them if you do that which they used to
do
you end up releasing demons because
they're coming out of hell well I kind
of feel like that came from a very
judeo-christian like old school yeah
when people have to punish for but I was
like that's really not in society's best
interest not in the long term no in the
long term another thing is this is a
person that is gonna have to live among
other people eventually and then law
enforcement takes the [__] brunt of
it because the dudes will fight to the
death to avoid being captured alive
because they don't want to go to prison
to that prison
you want it to be like well where
they're gonna send me is it's not that
bad I don't want to kill these dudes
over this
okay just send me there I'll be there
for a couple years and I'll be back up
it's a lot easier to deal with them when
they're when it's like that well I kind
of feel like and a lot of times too
especially in the United States because
we [__] throw people in jail for
anything but it's just kind of like most
people that go to jail it's for stupid
[__] and when they're young it's like
they'll grow out of it it's like you
know
they do stupid [__] when they're young
everybody does you know what I mean I'm
not talking about rape or murder or
anything like that but that's almost
jurisdictions right you get arrested 30
times and not do prison time
xanada says my uncle went to prison for
grand theft and started his own
carpentry business when he got out he
made six pictures a year he was totally
reformed yeah yeah see that's what I
mean it's like people like that like
stealing I'm not advocating stealing
cars obviously but it's just kind of
like [__] that kind of [__] yeah
especially if you're younger like if you
go to jail you do your time for it you
get out and you can put let's say it's
fine like I'm not really worried about
that like I said I'm worried about more
I I worry about violent criminals
because a lot of times
particularly with some kinds of violent
crimes that
I feel like that's kind of like a
proclivity that can't necessarily be
removed depends on the situation but it
depends on the person and there's a lot
of [__] that's wrong with the American
system one one of the things that's
wrong about it that one of the things
wrong with it is the concept of felon
they're starting to [__] keep track
of every [__] thing that happens to
this person then they start compounding
the [__] problems if a person does
something wrong
you're punished or you go to prison
when the sentence is served your rights
are restored you should have full rights
of a citizen that includes [__] gun
rights rights to vote right rights to
everything if you're too dangerous to
release don't forget to release them out
right
so I don't believe in this these dudes
running around with all this [__]
felony charges on them and [__] it just
compounds the [__] situ the problem
because they can't start a new life
can't get a good job here so I might as
well just go back to the gags
it's just stupid see yeah that's the
problem I kind of feel like
I don't know any system's gonna be
imperfect because humans are imperfect
that [__] did not exist until the SEC
until the 60s but I kind of feel like
depending on what you did like I said
this is a case-by-case basis obviously
if you're like some [__] serial
killer that's a whole other category
but if you did some [__] and you served
your time yeah you know well and
everything like that and they let you
out
then your rights are restored you should
have your rights restored because it's
like like I said if you just have all
these restrictions on them still yeah
they can't they can't ever restart a new
life right it's like they can't get a
job they can't do this and that it's
like how do you expect them to like get
back into normal life and like
contribute to them it's because they
didn't want that they wanted to make a
whole industry based on right that's
what they really wanted and like I said
I kind of feel like our whole system is
more based on like punishment yeah which
is like a really everything
money is what's based on and they have
whole systems based on this they're
making [__] tons of money off of it it's
just it's parasitic
here the situation it says that you
should in the in the U.S constitute
Constitution it talks about due process
that your rights cannot be removed
without due process that means you
become you go to prison
they did it under due process and then
once
so it takes a due process to remove your
rights
all right in other words a trial a legal
system then you go to prison to serve
the sentence when the sentence is served
when you've completed the sentence your
rights are restored
so it resets
you you know I mean that that's that's
really the way it should be I mean just
to release then don't release you right
right right
that's what I mean if they were free or
not one of the two they should release
you I mean they should at least allow
you the opportunity to you're either a
citizen or you're not try to start a new
life your shoes should be able to get a
job you should be able to get a house
you should be there shouldn't be
anything in between you're either a
citizen or you aren't because if they
kind of leave you hanging like right
then that just gives you incentive to go
back to like a like go back because
you're now because you're not marked
because well because your options are so
limited right like what else are you
gonna do you know they knew that though
they wanted to make a they want and this
is all [__] that happened after the 60s
70s 80s that are they just need to
dismantle that old system
and go back to the way it used to be
if the Sinners was served the sentence
was served you're free
you know your your rights are restored
yeah like I said if they thought you
were still a danger then they would have
never released don't let them out right
yeah right
yeah I agree with you on that
but uh so yeah Most states have it now
to where they could vote but they need
full restoration that's the way it
really should be
so yeah so this [__] uh
so after so like I said the judge
um was not real sympathetic to Jared
um and particularly after hearing
I think they're out there some I'm sure
they're out there somewhere like the
recordings
um that Rochelle did and like that other
people did of Jared over the years of
like [__] that he said over phone calls
and stuff
um and he was like I said he wasn't real
shy about all the [__] that he did hey I
went to Thailand hey I'd paid to have
sex with this 14 year old it was awesome
you know what I mean like he would say
[__] like that
so after the judge heard all of this
stuff he was like oh my God this
[__] so
like I said he actually um she actually
gave
um three and a half years more than the
prosecution was even asking for
and uh with 13 years before you could
even get parole
now because this is federal prison like
I said he did get his ass kicked One
Time by another inmate but other than
that
he seems to have had like a fairly cushy
prison life he's writing letters he's
allegedly taking cooking classes he
denies it but I don't really know what
the deal is there but another inmate
said about that
one thing that he said though was that
he said that he wanted to
um like I said he called this whole
debacle
a stupid mistake which
seems a little reductive to me I mean
stupid mistake is like
I don't know forget to put the trash out
oh my gosh right you know what I mean
it's not like oh several years of
going to Thailand to have sex with
miners you know what I mean it's just I
don't know that doesn't seem like a
stupid mistake to man it seems pretty
deliberate so I don't really know the
fact that he would like call it that
just says to me that he hasn't really
changed in any great degree the fact
that he would minimize it like that I
don't know
but he's trying to like say oh I want to
be in like I want to live an honorable
life if I want to be a good dude blah
blah I don't I'm not really sure how
much I believe that because the thing
about it is that
just like every other scumbag in prison
serial killers whoever pedophiles
crocodiles whatever you want to call
them
um they all have their
fans because it's a weird world out
there and there's a lot of freaky people
so Jared
um has some uh fans out there who I
don't know if they think that he didn't
do the [__] or
whatever but they still kind of like
um you know think he's awesome in some
degree so they write him letters and
um there is
there is footage out there or recording
like audio recordings of him talking to
one woman
who's been corresponding to him for
quite a while and he's you know
essentially asking her to like send him
nudes and stuff like saying what the
parameters are like what you can get
away with
like as far as sending pictures into the
prison like you can't he's like well you
can't say anything with boobs or [__]
but you know you could just send like a
regular picture you see you know he's
trying to like say but other than that
like everything so I don't really know
if he's changed all that much to be
honest with you um he still kind of
sounds like a dirtbag but
I don't know we'll see uh it's another
six years before he can conceivably get
out and um Russell Taylor is gonna be in
there for a much longer time
so I don't know he's gonna be like a
[__] old man him and his wife before
they [__] get out but that's the
thing I
I don't know so at so as we speak as of
this recording
which is
what month is it May May 20 20 23.
uh Jared is still in prison
Russell Taylor and his wife are also
still in prison for much longer now uh
Jared might get out in uh 2029
but we'll see how that goes I don't
really know
but
I don't know like I said
God this dude just pisses me off so much
I think the thing that pisses me off
there's a lot about him I know that but
it's like the thing that pisses me off
about him is that
I mean among many things
is that yeah he had a shitty child yeah
he was a fat kid yeah he couldn't do
this thing but that well yeah yeah but
it's like so I get that like that sucked
and it's like then you get in your 20s
you lose all this weight and suddenly
your life completely changes and then
suddenly you have all this money and you
have this freedom and you have this and
then you use that in the [__] worst
way imaginable he could have had the
easiest life ever
all he had to do and that's what that
kills me he should have got on got off
into these [__] big titty [__]
implant girls [__] like what they had
like look just go into the bigger is
better like subway might not have been
happy that he was like all with hitting
processes and stuff like look I don't
even give a [__] about that like I said
as long as everyone's consenting and
they're over 18 whatever go to town
um you know what I mean it's it's fine
it's I don't and I don't really think
anyone would have been bothered no one
would have been bothered it would have
been a tiny Scandal but it was like oh
well you know whatever
he had money it's like they a lot of
dudes would be like I do the same thing
it's like they wouldn't worry about it
and I'm not worried about it like I said
everyone's over age no one's doing
anything they don't want to do
um you know everyone's been paid it's
fine so it's just but the fact that he
just couldn't
keep away
from under eight and he just like was
blatant about it he's like asking
[__] hey can you hook me up with like
from nine year old the what the [__] why
it was taboo and he was getting away
with it I guess Tracy just shut up
what's up bro hey man because you guys
are still going on yeah yeah we're doing
yeah I know yeah the show's gone over it
has we're probably like hour four is to
no okay three three okay
he went too high Jenny yeah he lived
like a rock star and he fell hard yeah
yeah I mean ego Rockstar this definitely
this definitely does seem like a case of
a dude that had nothing nothing nothing
like I said he was fat all through his
childhood and his teenage years he
didn't have a girlfriend he didn't he
just sat in his room played video games
and then all of a sudden he's in his 20s
he's thin he has money he has all this
kind of stuff and he can just do
whatever the [__] he wants to and he
just went [__] buck wild with it yeah
which like I said I don't
there's lots of ways you could go like I
said I don't even I don't even have a
problem I don't have a problem with the
strip clubs I don't have a problem with
the drinking or the drugs or anything
like I said everyone was an adult yeah
it's fine
no one cares about that but the second
that you get Miners and animals and all
this kind of [__] involved yeah which
all of that was involved in this case in
case you're late coming in
um that's when we're gonna have a
problem had you just kept everything
why couldn't you just [__] even
[__] around your wife like I said
that sucks but
everyone's adults everyone's adult the
wife was into the [__] though too well
his wife was yeah yeah that was Russell
Taylor yeah that's right that's right he
had well Jared had two wives yeah his
first wife [__] off and was like yeah
[__] that he was abusive emotionally
abusive she said so that was even before
all this [__] happened so he was kind of
a [__] before and he had all the
money he wanted to do the sex tourism
you can do that
just well I don't like that but no you
can go you can go to sex tourism just
don't don't [__] [__] around with
those underage girls in the other
countries but that's something that's
literally it just means you're gonna go
to another country and [__] hookers all
you had to do sex terms just going to go
into another country and [__] hookers
that's all it means just make sure
everyone they do yeah you're right not
hard you're right not hard now some
countries might [__] be well 17's
legal it might be different you know in
each country I don't know
uh but just make sure it's legal
Wherever You Are
because the [__] he was doing in
Thailand wasn't legal even in Thailand
no you know
and the fact that he would come back and
just like brag about it to like random
people or people he didn't know that
well
um one shows that he wasn't all that
bright yeah
two just showed how out of touch he was
like he just thought it was okay or he
thought he could just like do whatever I
don't really get it I don't get all this
uh who's legal and who's not legal
[__] people wouldn't believe
the differences between countries like
if I remember correctly I think in
Canada a girl could strip
and be work at a strip club if she was
16. 16 I think it was 16.
that was that was back in the 80s I
don't know if it's still like that maybe
some Canadian my China chime in
and uh age of consent
in Mississippi and losing I think in
Mississippi during the time that I lived
there was 14.
now that doesn't mean you could take
pictures of them
and then it was like you know what I
mean because if you took pictures of
them that would be like child
pornography well yeah but I think age of
consent was 14.
uh they couldn't drink until they were
21 though
so the laws didn't quite make sense well
different people make different laws at
different times yeah that's they're all
just kind of cobbled yeah they don't
make any sense because it wasn't like
you know a single body like came up with
them all at one time but it's like this
is how we're gonna work everything out
it's just like [__] that's been cobbled
together over time yeah and I think you
could marry a girl with parental consent
to 13. in Mississippi
now when I was there in the 90s last
time I was there that law still stood
because we would laugh about it nobody
was doing that
that was some [__] from the 1800s it was
still on the books but nobody actually
did that
right so just because it isn't on the
just because it's a law on the books
doesn't mean that it's
common custom
you know it was just like everybody else
you got married at like 21 22 23 because
usually when they got married
High Desert uh004 has said doesn't seem
to have hurt Subway too much
I think that's because here's the thing
Subway we're big about like we didn't
know about any of this stuff because
like I said
allegedly people reported stuff to law
enforcement as well as as well as to
Subway higher-ups as early as 2007 or
2008. Subway says they didn't know
anything until the FBI raided Jared's
house in 2015.
however I will note and I'm not saying
this as any like one way or the other
I'm just noting this
Subway did starting in 2008 start to
minimize
their uh campaign featuring Jared bigot
and the reason that they gave was it's
like Well we'd already been using Jared
and our stuff for like almost 10 years
at that point it was getting stale so we
were kind of like pushing more on our
five dollar foot long thing which was
also a very popular promotion so but I
will note that um some people had
reported his uh behavior let's call it
that uh as early as 2007 or 2008. so it
could be that Subway Executives knew
that there was something going on with
him and were like yeah we're just gonna
kind of quietly phase him out they did
keep using him in their promotional
material though up until the FBI raid I
will say that so I don't know if they
knew I think but they did like
substantially tone down but but you have
to think that they had started the
campaign with him in 2000 so it had been
going on for like a long time so it
could be just a coincidence and they
were just like yeah we've been doing
this for 10 years at this point it's
like we're gonna go in a different
direction now so it might have been
coincidence but I don't know if I
totally buy that because people were
reporting him as early as that like to
Subway higher-ups so and the thing about
it too was that like the second that the
FBI raided Jared's house Subway was like
yep nope they like tweeted yeah we're
not we're severing all ties with him
like as soon as the FBI raided his house
so
they knew it didn't hurt their image in
the long run obviously because they're
still massively massively successful but
I do kind of feel like that's what
everybody Associates Jared with nowadays
not so much Subway so they did actually
like pretty successfully
um extricate themselves from that [__]
show well that happened in almost like a
pre-internet Time the internet wasn't
this mainstream back then
although Jared didn't get caught until
2015 so oh I didn't realize it was that
late yeah
yeah but it had blown over by that time
that advertising campaigning was long
gone senior 6 said Subway just let it go
because he made the money perhaps I kind
of feel like that was the case what
allegedly
um when someone said well uh because
like I said some people had reported
some of his questionable Behavior like
as early as 2007 2008 somewhere around
there
and Subway Executives said oh well he
just got married again so she'll
straighten him out
said something like that
you know what I mean oh and and we have
him with a counselor that will like get
rid of those
um crocodile uh proclivities that he has
you know what I mean so
it was that kind of sexual allegedly
allegedly I don't really know
did you know Subway did breakfast food
because I didn't I did not know that no
I didn't know that
I kind of feel like all fast food places
have to do breakfast now because that's
kind of like well that means I gotta go
in there and try it do you
well I don't know if the Circle K okay
it has it yeah because the Circle K down
the street actually does have a Subway
I've never eaten at that Subway in there
I just usually get to Circle K would
probably be like [__]
eggs cheese and and [__] ham slices
on [__] French bread that's probably
what it would be well it's just gonna be
like a variation of it's gonna be like
breakfast sandwiches I would imagine I
didn't know yeah I love that [__] I love
breakfast sandwiches I do too breakfast
sandwiches are one of the best things
ever yeah
uh yeah American Military 100 Subway's
food is what our Subway well and the
fact that there's like so much other
competition well in so many other sub
shops opened like you had like [__]
Jimmy John's which a lot of people like
a lot better
um Firehouse you know all these other
way is something that's in a gas station
here yeah okay that's
Circle K in the South has Subways inside
of it yeah you're drunk It's the middle
of the night you're on your way back
from the club you got to get gas it's
the only [__] that's open yeah look
where to get this
what it is now when I was in the army up
in Nashville Mike Kowalski who is a
buddy of mine up in Michigan he ended up
moving to [__] Nashville Tennessee
and while I was in the Army and it was
funny I was stationed at [__] Fort
Campbell and some weekends I go [__]
National hang out with Mike and and
here's my buddy from Michigan
he worked at a subway during that time
he was a Sandwich Artist but yeah he was
a Sandwich Artist back in like 93.
and uh he could run a whole Subway by
himself
all right and he told me he said the
problem with Subway's the bread and I
said everybody said yeah yeah everybody
says the bread is weird yeah yeah and he
says the bread comes in a frozen [__]
lump yep and if you cook it from Frozen
it doesn't taste good you're supposed to
take the [__] frozen dough out and
let it thaw because I let all my [__]
thaw before I start cooking sandwiches
and there's this and and he says try the
difference here's the and he would give
me free sandwiches he says this is it
this is [__] Frozen
and I [__] took a bite of that and I
was that sandwich yeah yeah it's okay
just try this one and it was a lot
better
so depending on how how [__] attuned
the staff was right okay
if the staff was allowing the [__]
frozen dough
to thaw and Rise it was a lot better
yeah but he said most staff didn't give
a [__] they cooked the [__] dough
well yeah they're just like I don't know
yeah I got it right they don't pay him
enough to get right but I go see Mike
he'd give me some free [__] Subway
all right and now here you wanted this
and that yeah yeah yeah now if I can get
that [__] he goes yeah and he goes that
shit's going out the bin anyway
yeah so he said but uh and uh his
sandwiches were good
honestly the only Subs that I used to
like at Subway were the like the seafood
ones yeah that was good too like with
the one thing well I make that [__] here
that's what I mean but we'll see that's
what I mean like you make that [__] now
so I don't need to go to Subway but yeah
I can be better here
crab with the K uh celery uh and uh
mayonnaise a little bit of lemon and uh
Old Bay seasoning yeah that's all it is
good yeah
Senor stick says I miss Quiznos I do too
kinda I didn't go there a lot but they
had good things I thought Quiznos was
Subway by another name no no no it's not
okay no it's not all right everybody
yeah Jimmy John's I Jimmy John's aren't
they
um aren't they like the number one in
that category at this point Jimmy John's
I feel like maybe I think the best I
think I've only eaten there once or
twice but I remember them being really
this sub chain I've been to is Firehouse
yeah well they make a lot of The Toasted
Subs yeah yeah I like I like Firehouse
too Jimmy John's is good too though like
for cold times they have hot ones too if
I think if I remember but I just had
cold ones when I went there okay so the
show's pretty much over right yeah yeah
we've covered everything so like I said
uh Jared still in prison yeah uh
Russell's still in prison probably not
getting it he'll probably die before he
gets out to be honest with you because
he got a way longer sentence but that
was because of that you know bestiality
yeah that he was into
aside from this we've still been working
on our other efforts regulars know what
we're talking about
we're gonna have a stream mate opening
we're gonna open uh we're gonna sell
some [__] uh videos of me and Jan
[__] around we've got some [__]
[__] in the can already it's good
I've given out a few [__] samples to
select people and you're like oh yeah
this shit's gonna be good if I can run
it by a [__] bill Quinn from Quinn
Studios he's like man you guys are going
to be awesome we're gonna run a stream
made show
which is gonna be kind of like uh
sidetracks kind of like a Side Tracks
but it can be X-rated
and for certain tips we can Jenny can
Flash titties we can [__] do all
they're all kind of fun stuff right and
it won't be in public though it's got to
go private for that but in like a few
minutes and
but it's going to be a fun show we got
all kind of fun props and stuff yeah
props we got good lighting we're gonna
change the [__] scenery because we
got a [__] background over here
we're gonna be selling videos you know
[__] Zach he's like I can't
understand why my favorite people are
[__] pimping themselves out Zach
we're straight okay straight people do
this [__] it was straightish straight
yeah she she yeah I forgot I forgot
about this straight-ish yeah straight
but uh
and uh we have some regulars from the
show sending us some of their content
[__] Oscar which we always appreciate
yeah [__] I saw Oscar in here yeah we
saw Oscar's videos with his sucking
his Texan ass his Texican ass with his
[__] hot ass [__] Irish American
[__] girlfriend it's very cute by the
way very cute red hand with like a big
old Shamrock tattooed on her ass
yeah she's cute um but we got all that
she wants to come down and [__] work
with Jed
we'll see what's it me and Oscar like
man we got to make this [__] happen man
but uh they're engineering all kinds of
engineering [__] behind the scenes
behind my back
I only find out about it yeah her name
was Misty yeah Misty was cute as [__]
but we'll see we're just gonna see how
things going we got mother products to
sell
because you know y'all ain't paying the
bills
like all the stuff that we shot we
couldn't shoot anything well this past
weekend because like I said I have a
full-time job now
yeah so I don't have a lot of time like
during the week but over the weekend
like last weekend uh we couldn't really
shoot anything because yeah of Tom's
stomach issue yeah I got like stuff like
well his you know I [__] ejected
myself a [__] test and it's
subcutaneous and that [__] [__] blew
up because it was too [__] powerful
yeah yeah so it's going down now we but
we did like Salvage it because we did
like do a photo shoot that we got like
some good [__] yeah it was just me yeah
but Jan dismasilla stuff but I still
have to edit the phone yeah I want to
see it I haven't seen it yet she's
holding this [__] secret to me I'm
not I just haven't had time to like edit
stuff I just don't have time yeah but
yeah so this weekend we're hoping to
like shoot some more stuff and because
like I said we want to have like a bunch
of video content up before we
I'm like looking forward to doing the
live streams I know you're looking
forward to like doing the videos which I
want to do like that'll be fun too well
I wanna I know I want to do this I want
to do the [__] stream base show yeah
yeah yeah I'm like I'm looking forward
to that I think that will be fun I think
that would be fun
um because well I'll be I could be on
there for six hours [__] around on on
that [__] yeah okay too I don't give a
[__] well because like I said it'll get
to a point where well you don't have to
worry about it yeah like on here
like you're gonna stick to a topic we
gotta [__] do it well I don't really
mind about that but it's just kind of
like especially when we're because we do
a lot of True Crime topics and so I
always have to like kind of be careful
about that's why I keep saying
feastiality and yeah
Kitty prawns yeah and stuff like that
because it's like I don't know what
things are gonna trigger like I don't
want to get the video pulled or like
demonetized or stream mate we don't have
to worry about that right and so like we
can just do whatever right so so we'll
slowly swing some of you guys over to
the [__] that we're doing on stream
stream mate unless it would be too weird
for you if it would be weird for you
then yeah it's too weird for you don't
worry about it don't worry we're the
people that have I'm not your threshold
for the [__] [__] weekend we'll talk
over there it'll be fun it'd be all
after hours [__] we're gonna be drinking
we're gonna be doing all kinds of like I
said it'll be just like a Sidetrack show
yeah except less limitations yeah except
it'll be able to get x-rated yeah if it
has if needs if need be
because me and Jen want to cut cut loose
sometimes so [__] talk all kinds well
that's what I mean like sometimes on the
Sidetrack show like especially it's
Friday night like we're drinking and I'm
just kind of like we're both you know
you guys know yeah we're both kind of
um I don't want to say we're perverts
we're not perverts no we're just wow
we're just wild so sometimes it's just
kind of like we're thinking about stuff
and I'm just like oh you can't do that
on YouTube or we can't see that on
YouTube yeah but it's like you know what
I mean like if we were on another Forum
like we could totally do that right I
think that would have said Yeah we're
definitely could flash tits we can
[__] do all kinds of [__] funny
[__] Trey says sidetracks after dark
yeah I actually I actually one of my
first ideas for the channel over there
was 13 o'clock after dark yeah or after
hours I was gonna call it but I think we
just ended up calling it 13 km because
that was just like easier it makes more
sense for our system right right right
right because it's like we weren't sure
I was like well do we want people that
are looking for the podcast to be able
to see that or like I kind of do but I
kind of don't right because I kind of
want them to be the deal with stream me
in order to be a player on stream mate
you must give them your credit card
information before you can chat in the
chat
if you're in the chat and you can they
have your credit card information you
can tip
one two five ten twenty or you can pay
other things it's a good system I went
over there as a tourist to see how it
worked security is good the the uh it's
it's a good show
what most girls are offering over there
is you know of course jerk off Services
all right but there's a lot more that
you can do over there
um
couples camming is a lot different than
single female caming all right couples
cammies more like [__] Side Tracks
but it can go way out of nothing can
happen
that's r or X or nothing can happen
that's x-rated in public it has to go
private right right so a person has to
pay has to switch over to a [__]
private chat other people can buy to go
into it to see what happens it only goes
on for a couple minutes and then boom
then you're back into the public chat
so nothing happens in public we ain't
hoes like that we don't [__] well
anything about it is that free but I
don't like personally like I actually
admire like girls that can do
um the solo stuff because it's like I
don't know if I could just do it like an
hours and hours long solo stream like by
myself it seemed like it was something
to talk about that's what I mean it just
seems like it would just be too much
burden like I would have to like find
hours of stuff to like talk about I have
to engage like all these people that are
coming in it's much easier
for me like if you're there because it's
like look if nobody's in the room or
nobody's talking like I can talk to you
we can just [__] around and talk and
like entertain right each other and then
like if somebody wanders in awesome yeah
you know what I mean I don't really like
the added burden of the pressure of like
and if it's just being me you know you
know I'm gonna be honest man if a good
plan good paying customer [__] comes
in and goes look man
here's the money y'all [__] get busy
no me and Jan will [__] throw down on
each other well yeah we'll do that if I
could help a [__] do his [__]
now another version another another
things out there is [__] ChatterBait
chatterbaits in public
which they say that that's actually a
good one just to get followers
all right uh but the thing is there's no
going private there
it's a little [__] less comfortable
for for me because you might have 5 000
people watching and only two paying
right
I I would feel like I would rather I
would rather the quality overhead yeah I
think I'm gonna go stream mate live
Jasmine supposed to be pretty good
that one and then there's another one
text Panther
yeah I've heard of that or Sex Panther
Sex Panther I thought it was text
Panther Sex Panther sext
Panther you get eighty percent of the
money yeah you see on on stream mate we
only get 40 something percent they get
65 percent
which makes sense because they got tight
security yeah I don't have a problem
with it like they're giving you a
platform and they're getting a security
in there again right yeah so
so um but it it'll just be a fun side
show we gotta [__]
start giving uh getting other revenue
streams and uh you know I sent out some
samples to this [__] some of our
regulars and like well finally
finally we've been talking about yeah
yeah it's because a lot of people
finally Tom's putting his money where
his mouth is man all that [__] I've been
talking about I gotta [__] prove it
you'll see y'all let's see I I can prove
it yeah we got lots of paper so far yeah
like I said we got to shoot some more
this weekend though yeah we'll shoot
some more we'll show you some more this
weekend now he's like what are we
shooting for because on those platforms
you can sell merchandise including
videos yeah like clips clips so we'll be
selling Clips or giving away Clips too
and also doing live streams and doing
live streams sure and then there are
other
um we're gonna do only vids
you can buy stuff from all those we'll
have other products up there for sale
and I'm pretty sure that you can sell
the same Clips across those three
platforms but I have to check first like
for the legality yeah
and it'll it'll be us you'll you'll know
you know we're still [__] making
jokes and [__] it's it's it's
you'll you'll understand when you see
like I said it's still us yeah it's just
yeah it's just something some [__] you
haven't seen yet other people's seen it
we do [__] weird [__] man we're from
a [__] god fetish scene okay so I can
it's not well not a not a whole bunch of
other people but some people have kind
of
messed around with us uh it's gonna be
like that
yeah yeah
Cindy or stick says Tom and Jenny would
you do HBO real sex or taxicab
confessions type show if invited uh
probably well I mean if they invited us
then they said we'll give you some money
to do it yeah I would do it yeah the
rules are like I said yeah
well the reason that we got we decided
to do this was because
we could just do [__]
in the house with me and you like I
don't have to like go out and like we
don't have to go out and have sex with
random people yeah and deal with all
that drama now people are saying they
come come they're gonna come check it
out
people are saying they're gonna check it
out yeah it'll be fun come check it out
because like I said I'm looking forward
we're gonna make new regulars also more
y'all but well the regulars that we have
here you'll be welcome to come over
there
I mean I don't think it's gonna be weird
but it's not weird for me but no
we know how to make this [__] [__]
noise I don't find it weird it's not
weird it's not weird it's not weird
seriously you don't even understand we
have like so we have right over there
like several feet away there's just like
a whole a nest of dildos yeah y'all
didn't know there's a bit much dildos of
it we well we ordered like a bunch of
props like for the show so we're like
scrolling through Amazon we're like What
are the best looking dildos that are
like on the market right now some kinky
ass looking [__] dildos it's like we
want some like cool looking ones that
are like they're not um so big you can't
use them well I'm just gonna say they're
not exactly functional
because I have tread I have tried them
all she tried them all out I tried them
all out but um yeah we tried them all
out and I was just kind of like I don't
know how I feel about that but they look
good on camera they look good on camera
where's the [__] space
they look good on camera though so I was
like that's kind of the important thing
I was like I'll figure out how to make
this [__] work I just want some [__]
that looks good on camera the crazy
Dragon one wasn't oh yeah yeah it's so
cool looking though I was like you have
to get that one because like I want to
do like a hole it looks like [__]
Rambo's [__] battle knife looks like
well no like because I want it because
it's uh the colors of it I said I wanted
to do like a lovecraftian because it
kind of looks like well they have one
that looks like straight up like a
tentacle I want to get that one too but
um even though that one looks really
uncomfortable I gotta say but this one
slightly less uncomfortable but still
pretty uncomfortable but it looks like
really cool like the colors if it's like
blue and purple and it's like monster
they have it like if you look on Amazon
under what do they have it under monster
dick or Monster
it's monster monster space Dragon
something yeah so I like what's called
space Dragon but it's really cool
looking super super uncomfortable but it
is like really nice looking yeah one one
girl reviewed it says she said it's like
chaos in your [__]
it's like okay
because I said well we gotta try this
stuff out because we ordered like a
bunch of them and I was like okay we
gotta we gotta test drive these so we're
starting them out and like so Tom's like
so is that like KSL like chaos I'm like
I'm not sure if that's the word that I
would use like I'm not really sure what
the word I would use it it's uh it's
it's painful that's for sure but uh I
don't know if it could have been the
position too maybe I don't know
maybe dogs maybe have been easier but
it's like chaos is not really the word
that I would use but I really know some
girls said they liked it but it's super
cool looking yeah and that's really all
there is when you're on the camera
um I think it's in the dick cubby
isn't it funny that like I I say dick
cubby and he knows exactly what I'm
talking about well a lot of them are
over there in my bat they're just kind
of like because you know they're just
kind of over there because we were using
them for video shoots but a couple of
them were still in the in the dick hubby
in the bedroom
so yeah
um
two or six are you saying Thomas Jenna
you two have a Sex Dungeon I don't know
if I'd call it it's not a Sex Dungeon we
don't have like chains or nothing like
that but you know what I mean you gotta
show them this this is what she's
talking about this is the this is what
I'm talking about
this is what I'm talking about this this
right here it's a little bit that way
look at this [__]
hold that [__] close to the screen well
if they have this in several colors too
yeah this was my favorite color
combination they also had like a red and
black one which was nice but I didn't
love the I liked this one because it was
kind of
like I said it was kind of uh
lovecraftian yeah it looks like
something out of a [__] monster but
like I said they have one in that same
color scheme but it looks more it's very
obviously a tentacle so it's like kind
of sharp at the end and I like that one
too but I was like well that would be
super uncomfortable but it would
probably look cool on camera though but
this one like looks cool on camera but
it's like yeah super uncomfortable but
yeah that was one of the ones we got
like I said we wanted ones that looked
cool on camera because that would we
wanted the whole branding to be
you know kind of like the whole we
wanted goth fetish all that kind of
stuff so I was like I don't want any
dicks that look like regular dicks
because I'm grossed out by this but I'm
not grossed out by actual dicks but I
don't really like
um
dildos that look like actual dicks I'm
like What's the [__] point of that I
want ones that look fun or that look
like decorative or look weird or look
something like that so I wanted like
some ones like that so we got like a
[__] this one we got like one that's
like red and black we got one that's
like clear you know we got like weird
looking ones you know what I mean
because I'm kind of more into that
yeah pretty much I mean I'm kind of used
to that at this point
at this point this would already be
demonetized even though I used
euphemisms or I tried to use euphemisms
like through the whole entire show like
I never said
the CP Words I Never Said it I always
said Kitty prawns I always said all that
kind of stuff but it's like it'll
probably be demonetized anyway just
because it's called Jared Fogle you know
what I mean so there are other videos
about Jared Vogel on YouTube there are
lots of them actually but
some of them have sponsors
I didn't really see if any of them had
ads uh get the dildo as if it says
Victor get the dildo that's shaped like
the butler's little hand and scary movie
there's so many so many like there's so
many cool ones like when I and even
Amazon has like a [__] oh that
[__] is unusable there
that's another one look at the balls on
this thing
you're gonna get demonetized by showing
them well Zach's accent that already no
I don't I don't think that you don't
think AI had even pick that up well yeah
well but yeah because it's like that
doesn't really
what did you just
because you broke some [__] nah knocked
over the little bowl
did you break it no
are you sure yeah okay he broke my
oatmeal bowl no okay
all right so I guess [__] man it's 11
o'clock yeah
probably I should go to bed because
Zach's laughing I get a cubby yeah and
Dick cubby was the [__] little thing
underneath the nightstand yeah well the
nightstand the nightstand it's a nice
time and it has
like a little thing underneath the like
a little Shelf
and I call it the cubby because like
sometimes he like climbs up in there
because sometimes yeah she's talking
about that dick and he started sticking
stuff down in there like all the dildos
and I was so I was like oh it's the dick
coming out but yeah and I started
laughing
yeah everybody says do you monetized
yeah pretty much
picture says uh all I gotta see is a big
old piece of black licorice yeah yeah it
does kind of look like that all right so
there's nothing ones over there too we
gotta spend money on cameras all kinds
of [__] at least we don't have to spend
money with our bras but basically we
don't have to we had all the [__]
clothes that we needed yeah and the
lighting
um we had to buy dildos
[__] had to spend over a hundred
dollars
yeah they're not cheap but yeah they're
not cheap especially the weird looking
ones yeah because we've got a dragon is
over a hundred dollars yeah I think it's
over with price they look cool they look
really cool on camera they do I mean we
got like one that was kind of like that
but there was like a it's a knockoff
badge like a knockoff but it's fine it's
you know it's it's fine it looks just as
cool I think
but yeah
mastinol says black one going in Tom's
Brown starfish
I already hit I already [__] got on
that subject [__] my friends the
first thing out of this math is what
happens if a rich dude comes in there
and wants to offer Jenny five grand to
hit you in the ass what are you gonna do
I'm gonna be like
I guess five grand I was like five grand
that's a whole motorcycle wow I guess I
had to get hit
he's laughing and I said [__] you know
you get hit in the ass for [__] fire
it's just her doing it I mean that's
what I said put it out you got to go to
the Proctologist and [__] [__]
stickers [__] figures and that's a
stranger that's a strange you didn't
know that dude putting [__] dick up
and putting his [__] fingers up in
your booty and then he's like yeah well
yeah
see it's all relative yeah yeah he's
Greek you know he's into that [__]
he's Greek our friends yeah yeah so uh
getting [__] up in his booty come on
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with getting it up in there all right
probably a legend yeah
I'm hearing all this [__] from these
[__] female friends of mine going oh
no I hit him in the ass with this and
this and that what
because these women are telling on you
you're missing out he's went nah [__]
women are [__] hitting dudes in the
booty
with these [__] strap-ons and [__]
and I'm just finding out about it now
you know he's just [__] it happen
I'm like what the [__] you people been
up that must cause psychological damage
to these women man [__] doing this
doing this [__] to these days why would
it I'm just I'm just imagining
I don't know
I don't know why it would cause any more
psychological damage than anything else
would causing it to the women
no we're not that fragile okay you ready
for the the [__] Victor says inflation
hitting the dildo industry hard sure
yeah yeah I'm sure I mean well
um I went to one of those sex toy
parties like
probably like 12 15 years ago and the
dildos were expensive back then too yeah
so they haven't really yeah they've
always been kind of expensive they've
always been kind of overpriced but I
mean they're good I mean the ones we got
are like good quality though so it's not
like it's not like Amazon carries a okay
selection they do well I used to have
like a long time ago I used to have a
shop where I sold like
um sex toys so I had a bunch of that
stuff but yeah most of them nowadays are
really really good quality they are
slightly expensive but they're usually
worth it they last a long time they got
designer [__] now like bad Dragon yeah
yeah that's designer
Victor says I had a patient like two
weeks ago that had a glass Coke bottle
stuck in his colon had to get it
surgically removed he said he didn't
know how it got he fell down that's what
they all said he fell down that's what
they all said he was walking he was
walking okay all of a sudden he's just
walking and then all of a sudden he
[__] tripped over the edge of the
carpet and fell down
and it went up and uh and it so happened
that there was a [__] just right Coke
bottle sitting right now walking to the
to the bathroom I mean as one does yeah
as one does yeah
that story's been told many times
I told you my sister worked at a GI
clinic she did billing and she's like
the [__] that I saw like people like
stuff up people's thoughts you would not
imagine she used to tell me like all the
stories about it it starts off with I
was walking
pretty much I was walking right or my
favorite one was I was on a lot like
they were painting they were on a ladder
and fell off and they're just like
happened to be something
that went right up there but that's my
favorite yeah because I'm like in the
dark and who put the Lube on it all
right yes like somebody put this KY on
here okay let's not
let's not have any Illusions let's not
kid ourselves here we know what's going
on
oh my God I had my coveralls on and
everything
and yet
and yet yeah Jones Parkin said I had to
walk away from the show to go make
dinner for my kids and now I come back
to this discussion he was bottle in the
butthole what the hell yeah and then he
said I know a guy who had a hamster
accidentally crawled his butt yeah
accidentally accidentally got [__]
tied up and had something tied around
his back leg too nobody knows how that
happened had a string tied on its back I
mean the hamster must have done it or
maybe his hamster friend yeah did it
maybe him and his hamster friend are
into Savage and they tied each other up
okay seriously I have to go to bed yeah
we gotta go I gotta get up so early I
have I have to get up at five in the
morning you guys and it's so I'm getting
like less than six hours sleep at this
point yeah and you know shut it down all
right all right I mean but you guys got
a good joke it's almost it's three hours
and 45 minutes all right
so um oh wait that was a triple yeah
Richard Gere that's what that was poor
Richard Gere I can't believe that he had
that urban legend yeah it's a legend
didn't have all right so we're gonna
wrap it up uh but we will be back Friday
night for the Sidetrack show where we
would just talk about whatever like we
did on this show kind of even though we
mostly sat on topic most of the time 80
70 of the time
um but yeah so come back Friday night
watch the Sidetrack show please have a
good rest of your evening please have a
good day tomorrow please remember to
like And subscribe and share and all
that kind of stuff comment
on the live stream because that always
helps with the algorithm and we'll see
you guys again on Friday night for the
Sidetrack show good night